Ihr könnt aufhören, mir Nachrichten zu schicken. Es ist ja gut, die Ligatour Europa, sie ist zurück. Wir sprechen jetzt über den europäischen Männerfußball. Wir blicken auf die Ligue 1, La Liga, Premier League und die Serie A und tun das mit Christian Bernhard, Chris McCarthy, Fabian Pakulat und– obacht– Jakob Haffke. Und jetzt kommt das ikonische Intro. Und nun im Programm der Rasenfunk.
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen in einem der Lieblingsformate von vielen von euch da draußen, zumindest laut Ergebnis unserer Hörerinnenbefragung. Deswegen hallo und herzlich willkommen. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost und ich begrüße hier eine fast bekannte Runde. Wir haben aber ein neues Gesicht mit dabei und eine neue Stimme. Jakob Haffke ist hier. Jakob, schön, dass du in der Ligatur mit dabei bist.
Hi. Moin, schön, dass ich hier sein kann.
Ja, aber wirklich. Magst du uns zwei, drei Worte zu dir sagen? Woher könnte man dich vielleicht schon kennen?
Man könnte mich kennen aus dem Flugkopfball, also dem St. Pauli und Werder-Podcast, den ich mit Rufen Peter zusammen mache. Ansonsten kann man mich lesen bei 90 plus und wer im Februar müsste es gewesen sein, dass St. Pauli spezial vom Rasenfunk gehört hat, er könnte mich da auch schon gehört haben.
Februar war das, ja krass, wie lange das schon wieder her ist. Genau, also Jakob ist jetzt auch regelmäßig mit dabei und damit, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, versuchen wir, die Liga 1 wieder öfter mit dabei zu haben. Es wird weiter so sein, dass wir immer mal wieder auch in die Niederlande blicken und da so ein bisschen so durch rotieren. Das hat dann wahrscheinlich terminliche Gründe eigentlich fast immer. Aber, Jakob, schön, dass du da bist. Lasst uns gleich reinstarten. Wir haben natürlich wieder ein pique-packes volles Programm und Fabian darf sehr gerne mal beginnen. Fabi, erstmal schön, dass du wieder da bist. Schöne neue Ligatour-Saison wünsche ich uns beiden oder uns allen natürlich. Was hast du uns denn als erstes Thema mitgebracht?
Ja, Buenos Dias aus Spanien. Ich freue mich auch sehr, dass es wieder losgeht. Und La Liga hat natürlich auch schon begonnen. Dritter, vierter Spieltag. Wir können noch nicht so viel natürlich sagen, aber untäglich grüßt das Murmeltier. Das können wir tatsächlich dann schon wieder völlig unüberraschend sagen. Nämlich Real Madrid und Barcelona grüßen schon wieder von der Spitze. Wer hätte es gedacht? Aber dieses Jahr besonders aufgefallen ist in Spanien, auch in der Sommertransferperiode. Der Adalasse in La Liga geht weiter. Die Kostenkontrolle in La Liga ist nach wie vor sehr heftig. Und da wird der Stift sehr weit oben angesetzt. Und dementsprechend müssen die Vereine sehr danach schauen, wie sie ihre Finanzen gestalten. Und man hat es gemerkt, dass die spanische Liga sogar unter der Bundesliga, unter der Serie A und natürlich unter der Premier League in Transferausgaben war. Es ist nach wie vor so, dass viele Talente die spanische Liga verlassen. Entweder es gibt ja auch nicht viele Möglichkeiten in Spanien, Real Vasa, vielleicht noch Atletico Madrid und dann geht es eigentlich in die Premier League. Oder auch zu großen Clubs nach Frankreich oder nach Deutschland, wo auch immer. Gerne auch nach Saudi-Arabien neuestens ja auch. Aber das ist mir aufgefallen und ich befürchte vor allen Dingen, dass die Schere noch größer wird zwischen diesen großen Clubs, Real Vasa. Dann wird schon die Schere ziemlich groß, auch schon zu Atletico Madrid und von Atletico Madrid zum Rest wird es dann nochmal krasser. Und besonders heftig ist es so, ab Platz 10, 11 nach unten, da sind wirklich die Budgets der Vereine teilweise deutlich unter denen der Bundesliga. Ich glaube, der HSV, habe ich gesehen, hat einen Marktwert von ungefähr 100 Millionen Euro und ist einer der dritt oder viert schlechteste in der Bundesliga. In Spanien haben die letzten 6, 7 Vereine so ein Budget von 55 Millionen Euro. Also, ich befürchte einen weiteren Qualitätsverlust in der Liga, was nicht die beiden Top-Teams anbelangt, aber alle anderen, glaube ich, werden doch mal ein Stück qualitativ verlieren.
Und das liegt, habe ich jetzt richtig verstanden, hauptsächlich an den Transfers vor allem in die Premier League. Also, dass eben quasi jeder, der gerade auslaufen kann und möglicherweise mal von einem riesen Talent zu einem sehr, sehr guten Spieler wird, dass der weggekauft wird im Zweifel.
Ja, wir haben es jetzt gesehen kurz vor dem Deadline-Day, was da noch alles passiert ist. Da haben halt kleine Vereine, wie zum Beispiel Vier Real, um ein Beispiel zu nehmen, Jere Maipino, Nationalspieler Spaniens nach Everton verloren. Oder ein ganz kleines Team wie Getafe, ihren besten Spieler, Cristiano, äh, Cristiano und nicht Cristin, Uche, zu Crystal Palace, glaube ich, verloren. Weil die dann einfach a, nicht mehr mithalten können finanziell und b, sie diese Einnahmen aber auch brauchen, um andere Spieler noch einschreiben zu können, in den Profikader. Und, ähm, klar, ähm, also, wo, wo soll denn die Qualität dann gehalten werden? Ehm, bei Betis Sevilla ist es zum Beispiel auch so ein Verein, den ich relativ viel verfolge. Ähm, die spielen nach wie vor international und sollten eigentlich gut aufgestellt sein, die krebsen rum jedes Mal und schauen, dass sie noch den ein oder anderen Spieler einschreiben können, müssen noch den ein oder anderen verkaufen. Und ja, es ist einfach, es ist einfach sehr, sehr schwer für die, für alle Klubs bis auf Real Barca und vielleicht noch Athletik Bilbao, die sehr gesund wirtschaften, wie wir ja wissen. Ähm, alle anderen müssen schon ganz schön kämpfen.
Da würde ich gerne die anderen mal kurz mit reinholen, weil in der Bundesliga haben wir das ja mitverfolgt. Da kann man irgendwie eine ähnliche Argumentation fahren, dass du sagst, ja gut, im Zweifel jeder, also, bei Mansambi von Freiburg zum Beispiel kannst du jetzt schon drüber reden, ja gut, wenn der jetzt noch drei gute Spiele macht, dann spielt er auch nächstes Jahr Premier League. Und wir müssen jetzt gar nicht mit Nic Woltemade und so weiter anfangen. Jakob, ist das in der Ligue 1 denn auch so, dass man das Gefühl hat, ich meine, gut, französischer Fußball ist so prall an Talenten, das wäre jetzt die einzige Ausnahme, die ich mir vielleicht vorstellen könnte. Aber gibt es da eine ähnliche Tendenz?
Also die Ligue 1 ist ja, glaube ich, von den Ligen, die wir hier heute im Call haben, sowieso die Ausbildungsliga schlechthin. Und außer PSG kann, glaube ich, auch keiner wirklich richtig starke Spieler dann längerfristig halten. So ein bisschen an der Grenze wandelt natürlich immer Olympique Marseille, die ja auch durchaus mal kostspielige Transfers tätigen. Da wollte ich aber nachher auch noch ein bisschen drüber sprechen. Und ansonsten ist es aber schon so, dass viele Spieler auch nach Deutschland wechseln, nach England natürlich ganz viel. Also so. Aber es ist halt, wie du angesprochen hast, auch der größte Talentepool. Das heißt, vielleicht verliert man dadurch gar nicht so sehr Qualität, aber ich glaube vor allem auch, weil man es gewohnt ist. Und wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, ist es in Spanien ja vielleicht ein etwas Neujahrer-Trend und es war ja durchaus auch mal anders.
Durch das financial fair play wahrscheinlich, Fabian.
Ja, definitiv. Also viele Talente hat man am Anfang natürlich halten können und ausbilden können und haben halt auch dann eben kleineren oder mittelstarken Clubs geholfen, dann dann nach oben zu kommen. Aber die gehen halt auch immer schneller weg, wenn das große Geld winkt. Und das muss jetzt nicht mal Premier League sein, das kann, wie gesagt, auch Saudi-Arabien in dem Beispiel sein, was ich vorher genannt habe. Wir hatten ja vor zwei Jahren die Geschichte mit Gabriel Vega, der sehr jung von Celta Vigo plötzlich nach Saudi-Arabien gewechselt ist, jetzt glaube ich zurück nach Porto ist, aber solche Geschichten gibt es dann eben. Und nicht wirklich förderlich, würde ich sagen, für die La Liga oder für den Wert der La Liga.
Ja, wenn ich auf die Top-Transfers der Serie A gucke, also jetzt auf der Abgangsseite, Christian, dann sehe ich da als erstes Gala, klar mit Viktor Osemen haben wir mitbekommen, Retegi, der ist auch nach Saudi-Arabien gegangen, ist mir persönlich schon wieder durchgerutscht. Aber ist das auch ein Thema in der Serie A, dass man so viel Talent verliert? Chris darf gerade noch gar nichts sagen, weil er ist aufnehmende Liga quasi.
Ich glaube, Fabian hat es ja, glaube ich, ganz gut erklärt, dass die großen Namen, wenn dann das große Geld aus der Premier League winkt, und damit meine ich jetzt eben nicht nur die Ablöse für den Verein, sondern meistens geht ja auch ein sehr hochdotierter Vertrag für die Spieler damit einher. Ich glaube, das kennen wir jetzt erst seit einigen Jahren. Ich glaube, was die letzten Jahre so ein bisschen neu dazugekommen ist, ist halt durch diese wirtschaftliche Macht der Premier League, kann halt auch die Nummer 12, 13, 11 der Premier League einfach Ablösesummen und Gehälter hinlegen, wo dann, sage ich mal, mittlere oder bessere Clubs in den anderen von uns hier betreuten Ligen einfach nicht mehr mithalten können. Also, ich glaube, ein gutes Beispiel vielleicht aus Italien in diesem Sommer ist Dan Ndoye von Bologna, der Schweizer Nationalspieler, der ja eine riesen Saison mit Bologna hat, der mit der Schweizer Nationalmannschaft ja auch entscheidend. Den wollte Napoli, den wollte Conte. Conte hat da ganz offen danach auch darüber gesprochen. Das wäre einer seiner Wunschspieler gewesen. Und Napoli hat, glaube ich, bis zu 40 oder 45 Millionen auch geboten. Ja, und am Ende kommt halt einfach noch. Und Bologna hat halt gepokert, weil die logischerweise das meiste herausholen wollen. Das ist ja ganz normal. Und am Ende kam halt Nottingham ins Eck und legt halt 55 hin, weil die, glaube ich, für die Summe nicht lang nachdenken müssen. Und das Ende der Geschichte ist, dass ein Deu jetzt nicht in Neapel spielt, wo er eine tragende Rolle bei einem Champions League teilnehmen und beim aktuellen Meister wahrscheinlich haben könnte, sondern eben– also Nottingham ist jetzt auch logischerweise, nicht falsch verstehen, kein schlechter Verein. Aber das zeigt halt vielleicht, also der italienische Meister und einer der wirtschaftsstärksten Clubs in Italien muss sich dann halt nicht nur gegen City, Liverpool und Arsenal erwehren, sondern in dem Fall halt auch gegen Clubs, die ja vielleicht sportlich noch ein paar Plätze dahinter rangieren in England. Und ich glaube, die Entwicklung wird jetzt erstmal so weitergehen, würde ich mal meinen.
Ja, ich meine, zum Glück haben wir da in der Bundesliga noch keinen Fall gehabt, wo dem deutschen Meister irgendwie ein Spieler durch die Lappen gegangen ist, der dann in die Premier League gewechselt ist. Chris, wie blickst du denn darauf? Also es war ja schon immer so, dass eben die finanzstärkste Liga hat schon immer quasi mehr eingekauft als verkauft und das Geld verteilt sich ja dann auch. Es bleibt ja in einem Ökosystem. Trotzdem hat man den Eindruck, dass es irgendwie extremer geworden ist. Und wenn man sich die Kader vom Premier League-Vereinen anguckt, dann ist das völlig absurd. Also da sind da 23, 24 Topspieler und man denkt sich ja, aber die werden doch ja auch alle gar nicht glücklich hier. Wie blickst du auf das ganze Thema?
Ja, ich meine, zunächst einmal muss ich sagen, ich finde es manchmal ein bisschen sehr vereinfacht in den sozialen Netzwerken oder auch teilweise in deutschen Medien dargestellt, was die Finanzkraft der Premier League angeht. Da kommt immer direkt, ja, da ist ein Scheiß dahinter, da ist ein Besitzer dahinter. Ganz so simpel ist das natürlich jetzt auch nicht. Also wenn du dir mal die Umsätze der Premier League anschaust, da hast du halt einen riesen Vorsprung gegenüber den anderen Top-Ligen. England hat halt als 1. Liga es geschafft, sich international zu vermarkten. Dementsprechend sind die TV-Gelder ja deutlich, deutlich höher und dementsprechend ist auch mehr Geld in der Liga und dementsprechend gibt man auch mehr Geld aus, als wäre in der Bundesliga wahrscheinlich nicht anders. Das finde ich, muss man immer noch dazu sagen, weil das wird manchmal ein bisschen zu, wie soll ich sagen, manchmal ein bisschen mit ein bisschen Neid auch von manchen Vereinen gesehen. Aber es ist halt so. Und ja, zu deiner Frage mit den Kader, wenn du dir jetzt mal Arsenal anschaust, die haben ja sehr viel für die Tiefe gemacht dieses Jahr. Das ist ja schon absurd, wenn du die 2. Mannschaft ansiehst. Die könnte wahrscheinlich um die Top 6 spielen. Weiß nicht, ob das zu weit hergeholt ist, aber so die Richtung geht es schon. Und ja, ich meine, man sieht halt als Arsenal, als Liverpool hast du gesehen, wie stark man City ist und was für einen Vorsprung auch finanziell sie hatten. Und um da mitzuhalten, musst du eben auch so ein Kader auf die Beine stellen und auch so viel ausgeben. Es ist ja, was willst du machen? Das ist dann einfach ein Wettrüsten sozusagen in der Premier League. Und wer da nicht mitmacht, mitzieht, der wird irgendwann abgehängt.
Ja, und ich finde aber auch den, also das eine ist ja klar, du musst mitziehen. Und das erste, was du gesagt hast, das will ich aber nochmal unterstreichen. Also es wird immer so getan, als ob die böse Premier League ihr alles auf Pump macht und dass die alle Verlust machen. Aber de facto ist es so, das hat Swiss Rambl wieder ganz gut rausgerechnet für dieses Transferfenster, dass die Premier League, obwohl sie so viel Geld ausgegeben hat, wie selten profitabler geworden ist, die einzelnen Vereine, was eben einfach mit der Art und Weise zu tun hat, wie du Transfers verrechnest und wie du vor allem Abgänge verrechnest. Also wenn du einen Spieler, der noch einen 5-Jahres-Vertrag hat und den du mal für 80 Millionen geholt hast, dann musst du den ja über 5 Jahre, musst du ihn ja abschreiben. Das ist ein Verlust, den du in jedem Jahr hast. In dem Moment, in dem du ihn verkaufst, musst du ihn komplett aus den Büchern rausnehmen. Gleichzeitig musst du jeden Transfer einmal bezahlen und dann über die Laufzeit hast du einen laufenden Verlust. Und durch diese Finanzregeln einfach, die auferlegt sind, ist tatsächlich so, dass viele ihre Profitabilität gesteigert haben, weil sie entsprechend gehandelt haben, dass sie Spieler mit langen Verträgen zum Teil verkauft haben, jetzt einmal einen Verlust verbuchen, aber dafür wieder neuen Spielraum haben, eben im Sinne auch der liga-internen Financial Fairplay-Regelung. Also es ist alles gar nicht so einfach, wie man immer denkt, dass man sagt, ja gut, die verschulden sich halt alle wild. Die Schuldenquote ist eigentlich besser geworden in der Premier League in den letzten zwei, drei Jahren.
Ja, vor allem wenn man jetzt auch auf Liverpool schaut, da kommt auch noch der Faktor dazu, wie gut Liverpool verkauft. Das darf man auch nicht vergessen. Klar, die haben eine halbe Milliarde ausgegeben. Da kann man auch zu Recht das irgendwie vielleicht ein bisschen hinterfragen oder seine Kommentare drüber geben. Aber klar, Luis Díaz hat jetzt einen guten Einstabat bei Bayern gemacht, aber ob der 70 Millionen Wert war in dem Alter, wage ich mal zu bezweifeln. Quansa für 35 Millionen, also das sind schon sehr hohe Summen für die Qualität, die dahinter steckt und dementsprechend kann man auch sehr viel ausgeben.
Und das ist nämlich Quansa, ich glaube, Quansa kam doch aus der eigenen Jugend, oder? Ich glaube, ja. Genau, und das ist nämlich dann das, das ist quasi der Goldstandard unter den Transfers. Du hast einen Spieler, der steht mit 0 Euro Wert in den Büchern. Und zum ersten Mal machst du ihn zu Geld, wenn du ihn verkaufst, weil dann kriegst du die 35 Millionen und das ist nämlich der größte Faktor, der diese Profitabilität steigert. Und das gehört eben mit dazu. Also Liverpool hat extrem gut gewirtschaftet und schafft das eben innerhalb aller, sowohl der Juve, der Financial Fair Play Region, als auch der Liga-Enternen, die noch ein bisschen strenger sind, schafft es da drin zu bleiben, weil man auch eben einfach sehr viel mehr Geld einnimmt. Und das ist eben auch nicht nur TV-Geld, sondern was war das Trikot-Verkauf für 700 Prozent nach oben? Irgendwie so ähnlich. Also es ist brutal, aber natürlich stimmt das, was Fabian uns erzählt hat. Für die Ligen ist das ein Problem, dass eben da die Schere dann zwischen den Top-Clubs in den Ligen und denjenigen, die eben abgeben, aber nicht neu kaufen können. Also Bayern konnte sich immerhin ein Luis Dias noch leisten, egal ob er jetzt überteuert ist oder nicht. Das kann halt Athletic Bilbao dann nicht. Hängt bei denen auch noch an anderen Gründen, aber ihr versteht meinen Punkt, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Das ist ein Thema und ich glaube, das werden wir auch in allen Ligen, eben exklusive der Premier League, dann auch mitverfolgen können, dass die Schere da auseinandergeht. Das ist leider dann auch am Ende ein bisschen einfache Mathematik. Ich finde aber, dass wir mit diesem Thema…
Ein kleiner Punkt. Sorry, Max, nur ganz ein kleiner Punkt. Ich würde schon bei all dem auch noch mit einfließen lassen, nur ganz kurz. Ich glaube, für viele kleinere Vereine in den anderen Ligen ist das auch eine Chance, teuer in die Premier League zu verkaufen. Also wenn wir uns zum Beispiel anschauen, wie sich Frankfurt allein die letzten Jahre, was die an Ablöse generiert haben, teilweise durch Verkäufe nach England und das dann gut reinvestiert haben, wenn wir uns zum Beispiel Atalanta hernehmen, die vor wenigen Jahren Rasmus Heul und für knapp 80 Millionen zum Manchester United verkauft, jetzt Retege für 65 Millionen nach Saudi-Arabien. Wenn die das Geld wieder clever reinvestieren, dann glaube ich, hast du zumindest Liga intern dann einfach mit so riesigen Ablösensummen, die du halt fast nur in England generieren kannst, also durch Verkäufe, logischerweise schon auch ein Fund, mit dem du dich bei der nationalen Konkurrenz, wenn du das wieder clever reinvestierst, gute Scouting, sind das schon auch Möglichkeiten, würde ich sagen, die du dir da erarbeiten kannst, gegenüber der nationalen Konkurrenz.
Und eben richtig Kohle machst du mit Eigengewächsen, weil eben wie gesagt, jemand, der einen Profivertrag bekommen aus der Jugend kommt, der steht mit 0 Euro im Eigenkapital, also der bringt dir da gar nichts. Wenn du ihn aber verkaufst, hast du auf einen Schlag Geld, und liquide Mittel, deswegen der SC Freiburgweg ist dann schon quasi der, der auch wirtschaftlich der Beste ist. Aber wir sind damit indirekt auch schon bei Olympique Lyon gelandet, Jakob. Denn auch da wurde viel über Zahlen gesprochen und nicht nur über Sportliches. Und das ist dein erstes Thema, was du mitgebracht hast aus der Liga. Also du hast jetzt die große Herausforderung, in 10 Minuten zusammenzufassen, was da los war. Leg mal los.
Ja, es zieht sich ja schon ziemlich lange bei Lyon. Also das ist jetzt nicht nur auf diese Saison bezogen, sondern es ging ja schon im Herbst der letzten Saison, vergangenen Saison, los, wo das erste Mal so ein bisschen ja bekannt wurde, dass Lyon vorübergehend hieß es damals immer noch zum Saisonende zwangsabsteigen muss. Und auch da ging es um Finanzen, Verstöße gegen Budget-Vorgaben. Ich finde, in Frankreich wird das immer nicht ganz so viel kommuniziert wie in Spanien, aber auch in Frankreich gibt es halt von der nationalen Finanzaufsicht Vorgaben, wie viel dürft ihr ausgeben im Jahr und vor allem muss man auch eigentlich Garantien hinterlegen. Und bei Lyon war ja damals noch John Texter an der Spitze als Präsident, der ja auch Mitglied der Eagle Football Group ist. Und der hat halt meistens nicht so wirklich Garantien hinterlegt, sondern immer nur gesagt, ja so und so wollen wir ja an Geld kommen. Zum Beispiel gab es da auch immer die Diskussionen, ob er dann zum Beispiel Transfererlöse, die er innerhalb seines Multiclub-Ownerships in Butterfogo generiert hat, dass er die dann an Lyon weiterleiten wollte, wo aber dann natürlich auch die französischen Zuständigen gesagt haben, ja so funktioniert das aber nicht, das Geld müsst ihr auch schon selber verdienen. Und dann schwelte oder war eigentlich immer so im Hintergrund, aus Lyon hat man immer gehört, ja wir schaffen das schon und wir werden auf jeden Fall nicht absteigen, sodass dann tatsächlich zum Saisonende relativ überraschend, zumindest für viele, kam, dass halt das Urteil bestätigt wurde, weil sich augenscheinlich nicht genug getan hatte von Vereinsseite aus, um diese Zweifel an der finanziellen Belastbarkeit von Lyon irgendwie zu beseitigen. Und da war dann erst mal die Aufregung groß. Man muss natürlich auch sagen, Olympique Lyon ist natürlich jetzt nicht mehr so groß wie Paris Saint-Germain, aber war ja in den Nuller-Jahren das Zugpferd schlechthin in Frankreich, siebenmal in Folge Meister geworden damals. In der Champions League ist man nie so richtig weit gekommen, aber hat ja zumindest vereinzelt auch für Aufsehen gesorgt, hat eine der renommiertesten Jugendabteilungen in Frankreich. Also es ist schon ein richtig, richtig großer Name, wo auch der Abstieg, was echt eine heftige Zäsur bedeutet hätte, nicht nur für den Verein selbst, sondern glaube ich auch für die ganze Liga. Und dementsprechend hat Lyon dann natürlich, wie es dann immer läuft, Einspruch eingelegt dagegen. Ich finde bemerkenswert tatsächlich, dass es halbwegs schnell auch dann alles behandelt wurde. Die letztendliche Entscheidung war dann ja, dass Lyon drinnen bleiben darf in der Liga. Maßgeblich dafür verantwortlich war aber auch, dass John Texter gesagt hat, okay, ich ziehe mich zurück, beziehungsweise ihm gesagt wurde, zieh dich zurück. Wie das dann so ganz genau abgelaufen ist, ist natürlich dann auch immer die Frage. Aber neu an der Spitze bei Lyon ist jetzt mit Michelle Kang, eine weitere Person aus der Eagle Football Group. Die kennt man ja vor allem auch aus dem Frauenfußball. Da hat sie ja eigentlich so das erste wirklich große Multiclub-Ownership im Frauenfußball. Ich glaube, da muss man jetzt auch nicht viel mehr zu sagen, dass es da ja natürlich auch Fragezeichen gibt, wie cool das alles ist. Aber ihr gehört zum Beispiel ja Washington Spirit. Jetzt seit dieser Saison auch der Erstligist, die London City Lionesses. Und auch vorher war sie in Lyon auch schon ein bisschen engagiert, aber halt hauptsächlich auch in der Frauenfußball-Seite, wo man auch sagen muss, die Frauenfußball-Abteilung in Lyon wurde auch abgespalten inzwischen. Die heißt jetzt auch OL. Lyon, also hat auch einen anderen Namen, spielt aber auch noch im Lyon-Stadion und so. Also sie ist nicht komplett getrennt vom Verein, aber man hat da zumindest eine Linie schon gescheitert. Also das ist etwas getrennt auf jeden Fall. Und sie ist jetzt aber auch bei der Männer-Abteilung von Lyon an der Spitze. Außerdem auch Michael Gerlinger noch, den man auch von Bayern vielleicht noch kennt. Der war da mal eine Zeit lang Vizepräsident. Ist jetzt bei Lyon der neue Generaldirektor. Und da hat es halt so weit geklappt, dass man dann der DNCG die nötigen finanziellen Mittel aufzeigen konnte. Soweit ich weiß, hat man auch gesagt, okay, wir haben hier ein Konto, da ist genug Geld drauf, damit wir in dieser Saison unser Budget einhalten können. Und man musste aber auch reichlich Spieler verkaufen, um dann letztendlich in der Liga bleiben zu dürfen. Hat das dann aber geschafft und spielt deswegen jetzt weiterhin in der Liga.
Lass mal ganz kurz noch bei Textor und der Eagle Holding bleiben. Also wo ist denn jetzt dann der Unterschied, wenn weiter die Holding den Verein besitzt, mehrheitlich, aber halt Textor nicht mehr der entscheidende Mann ist, aber jemand anderes aus der Holding? Ich verstehe es nicht so.
Also das war nicht der entscheidende Faktor, aber ich glaube einfach der Unterschied in der Art und Weise, wie man mit solchen Problemen umgeht, zwischen Jon Texter und Michelle Kang. Weil Michelle Kang gesagt hat, okay, die DNCG will, dass ich nicht nur sage, ich werde das Geld irgendwann haben, sondern ich zeige ihnen, wir haben das Geld. Und bei Jon Texter war halt immer so, ja, wir haben das dann irgendwann. Oder wir machen dies und das und dadurch bekommen wir Geld und dadurch können wir uns das dann auch leisten, was wir hier vorher schon ausgeben. Und das ist halt einfach der Grund. Also es hängt, und vieles hängt sich halt so ein bisschen an der Person. Jon Texter auch, weil er auch ja ein wahnsinnig polarisierend aufgetreten ist. Letztes Jahr sich ja auch immer mit dem PSG-Präsident gezofft hat, öffentlichkeitswirksam und so. Und ich glaube, da war man dann auch vielleicht von vielen Seiten auch ganz froh, dass er sich jetzt eigentlich zurückgezogen hat. Aber die an der Besitz, an den Besitzverhältnissen an sich hat sich nichts getan, das ist total richtig.
Okay, also nicht alle, nicht alle waren, glaube ich, froh. Kannst du mal die Crystal Palace-Fans fragen. Das ist jetzt dann nochmal...
Das ist dann natürlich was anderes.
Das ist natürlich auch der Grund, warum es so schnell ging, weil du es vorhin erwähnt hast. Weil die UEFA macht bei sowas dann Druck, weil Lyon war für die Europa League qualifiziert, Crystal Palace eigentlich auch. Und da musste schnell eine Entscheidung getroffen werden, weil die frühen Qualifikationsrunden ja schon relativ früh losgehen. Deswegen, aber gut, dann lass uns, auch wenn man noch lange über dieses Thema aufsprechen könnte, dann aufs Sportliche blicken. Du hast schon gesagt, viele Spieler wurden verkauft, aber trotzdem war ja der Start jetzt gar nicht so schlecht in die Saison.
Nee, was tatsächlich ein bisschen überraschend kam, weil es ist halt auch sportlich ein riesiger Umbruch gewesen. Ryan Cherki ist zu Manchester City gegangen. Also das größte Talent, was die Lyon-Akademie in den letzten Jahren so rausgebracht hat. Jetzt auch nicht für so eine ganz teure Summe, weil natürlich auch jeder wusste, okay, bei Lyon ist ordentlich Verkaufsdruck da, aber trotzdem hat man da mit Mittel garantiert. Man hat ansonsten mit Lucas Perry auch noch den Torwart, den letztjährigen Stammtorwart, an Leeds United verkauft. Also auch da sieht man vielleicht so ein bisschen das Gefälle, ist halt dann auch der Aufsteiger in der Premier League gewesen, der dann den Keeper genommen hat. Und man hat vor allem auch die Verträge von ganz vielen Allstars nicht verlängert. Also Alexandre Lacazette, der ja zum zweiten Mal bei Lyon war, ursprünglich ja auch aus der Akademie, ist jetzt in Saudi Arabien. Auch Nemanja Matic, Jordan Veretou, Saeed Ben-Rama, die teilweise wie Ben-Rama aber auch sportlich keine große Rolle mehr gespielt haben, aber halt große Verträge hatten, sind allesamt nicht mehr da. Man hat auch den Leihspieler Thiago Almada, der bei Botafogo unter Vertrag steht, nicht weiter beschäftigen können. Und man hat vor allem am letzten Transfertag auch noch George Mikotatse abgeben müssen. Auch da hat man von Spielerseite schon gehört, dass er das halt eigentlich gar nicht weg wollte, aber gehen musste. Man muss dazu sagen, Mikotatse kommt aus Lyon, ist seit der Kindheit Lyon-Fan gewesen, war jetzt nur ein Jahr da und musste jetzt wieder gehen, weil er halt so mit der sportlich wertvollste war oder der finanziell wertvollste Spieler war, den sie irgendwie verkaufen konnten und hat dadurch natürlich auch riesige Lücken in den Kader gerissen. Und gerade beim Abgang von Mikotatse, weil der jetzt auch relativ kurzfristig kam, muss man auch schauen, wie sich das jetzt zeigt, weil Lyon eigentlich keinen, ja zumindest keinen nachgewiesen guten Mittelstürmer für Ligue 1-Niveau mehr im Kader hat, durch den Abgang von Mikotatse.
Da hat er einen echten Schnapper gemacht, muss man sagen. Schade, dass er nicht so leih ist dann, sonst hätte vielleicht der FC Bayern zugeschlagen. Wobei, ich darf nicht immer so viele FC Bayern-Witze machen, ja, habe ich neulich gelesen im Feedback. Ich entschuldige mich. Sorry Jakob, mach weiter.
Auf der anderen Seite hat man bei den Neuzugängen schon auch gesehen, dass man halt nicht so das Geld, was man eingenommen hat. Also man hat einen Transferüberschuss von 70 Millionen jetzt am Ende der Transferphase, was aber wie gesagt auch nötig war. Das heißt, man konnte auch gar nicht so viel reinvestieren. Man hat für 10 Millionen Teiler Morten aus Liverpool geholt. Ich glaube, durchaus interessant, auch wenn der fast nur in der Champions-Chip gespielt hat, hat jetzt aber auch einen guten Saisonstart hingelegt auf der Doppel-6. Dann hat man einen neuen Torwart geholt mit Dominik Greif aus Spanien. Jetzt auch nicht der allergrößte Name, der jetzt tatsächlich zum Start auch noch gar nicht gespielt hat, aber jetzt ab dem nächsten Wochenende im Tor steht, weil Rémi Descamps sich verletzt hat, der Stammtorwart. Und dann hat man noch andere Spieler geholt, wie Adam Karabetz, der zum Beispiel letzte Saison an den HSV ausgeliehen war, also 2. Liga in Deutschland gespielt hat. Und es sind nicht die großen Namen, Ruben Kloyvat, der Bruder von Justin Kloyvat, Pavel Sulc, oder auch Routinier Rashid Gezal, der auch schon früher bei Lyon war, jetzt eine Zeit lang vereinslos war, nachdem er in der Türkei gespielt hatte. Also es haut einen jetzt nicht vom Hocker, aber bisher funktioniert es sehr gut, was Lyon auch gemacht hat. Und man hat jetzt nach vier Spielen drei Siege geholt und eine Niederlage. Und auch diese Niederlage, die jetzt am letzten Sonntagabend gegen Stadtrännen kam, war dann vom Spielverlauf her auch eher überraschend, weil man ja lange Zeit 1-0 geführt hat und dann erst nach einer sehr dämlichen roten Karte für Tyler Morton noch 3 zu 1 verloren hat in der Schlussphase. Also sportlich läuft es eigentlich sehr gut. Und das, obwohl ja auch, was wir jetzt noch gar nicht besprochen haben, Paulo von Seca weiterhin auf der Tribüne sitzt dauerhaft, weil er ja im März einen Schiedsrichter sehr aggressiv angegangen ist und dann ja für ein halbes Jahr gesperrt, in den neun Monate gesperrt wurde und erst im November überhaupt an die Seitenlinie zurückkehren soll. Also da auch bemerkenswert, wie Lyon da mit dieser Situation umgeht und im Grunde das ganze, der ganze Trubel drum herum und auch innerhalb der Mannschaft sich auf dem Platz gar nicht so richtig zeigt. Und da sind halt ein paar Spieler sehr wichtig. Also Corentin Toulisot ist so einer der ganz wenigen erfahrenen Stützen, die noch da geblieben ist, der übernimmt wahnsinnig viel, ist Kapitän der Mannschaft, ist auch sehr torgefährlich, spielt jetzt häufig so als Zehner und ist dann ganz viel auch im Strafraum präsent, hat jetzt auch gegen Startrennen zum Beispiel das 1-0 gemacht. Ansonsten ist mit Malek Fofanar auch noch eins der großen Talente da, allerdings nicht selbst ausgebildet, sondern den haben sie vor ein paar Jahren auch geholt. Das ist ein Außenstürmer der Bayern, meine ich auch bei den Bayern im Gespräch, sogar in dieser Transferphase zum Beispiel. Und da stand auch immer noch zur Frage, ob man den nicht vielleicht sogar auch noch abgeben muss. Da ist es zumindest ganz gut, dass sie den noch halten konnten. Aber ansonsten ist es dann doch eher eine solide Mannschaft vom Blick auf den Kader als jetzt eine Mannschaft, von der man unbedingt erwarten würde, dass sie vorne mitspielt. Muss man jetzt natürlich auch gucken, wie es dann in den nächsten Wochen weitergeht, auch mit Doppelbelastung und so weiter, da der Kader jetzt auch nicht super breit ist. Und natürlich die Frage, ob man es vielleicht auch schafft, wieder eigene Jugendspieler zu integrieren, einfach notgedrungen und dadurch dann natürlich auch neue Werte zu schaffen, im besten Fall.
Im besten Fall. Also drei Siege zu Beginn, eine Niederlage geht jetzt dann gegen Utrecht, unter anderem ja auch dann in der Europa League weiter. Also bei Lyon war viel, viel los, alles haben wir noch gar nicht besprechen können, aber das war sowieso von Anfang an eine Mission, die zum Scheitern verurteilt war. Wir gehen jetzt nochmal nach Spanien, denn Fabian, der kurzfristig eingesprungen ist, muss gleich noch weiter. Fabian, du hast uns noch zwei kurze Themen mitgebracht, bevor wir dich verabschieden. Was ist denn das?
Ja, ich würde ganz gerne kurioserweise über Riyal Madrid sprechen, was ich eigentlich gar nicht so gerne mache. Aber in dem Fall ist es eigentlich so die große Neuerung in La Liga, weil sie haben ja mit Xavi Alonso einen neuen Trainer, und der sorgt tatsächlich für einen großen sportlichen Wechsel bei Riyal Madrid. Ich habe mit einigen Fans gesprochen hier, und die sind alle wirklich sehr angetan. Die waren alle sehr ermüdet vom Angelotti-Fußball, vor allen Dingen in der letzten Saison, und sind sehr amüsiert, dass jetzt wieder Bewegung drin ist, sage ich jetzt mal, ganz salopp bei Riyal Madrid. Ja, Riyal Madrid ist auch sehr gut gestartet in die Liga, gewinnt zwar relativ knapp, es ist noch nicht alles rund, aber man merkt, dass dort wieder richtig Zug drin ist. Es wird sehr viel rotiert, was, glaube ich, so in der Stimmung im Kader im Moment ganz gut tut. Es wird natürlich, Surprise, Surprise, bei Xabi Alonso, ein hohes Pressing gespielt und das kennt man bei Riyal Madrid eigentlich auch nicht, dass man irgendwie auf den Ball geht, sondern da ist es eigentlich auch eher gewohnt, den Ball ständig zu haben. Und ja, es ist irgendwie, läuft ganz gut zusammen oder hat ganz gut angefangen jetzt für Riyal. Und einige Schlüsselspieler sind auch wirklich in Topform im Moment, zum Beispiel Mbappé, der jetzt eigentlich so die gesetzte Neun ist, nachdem man in den letzten Jahren nicht so ganz klar ist, spielt er lieber auf dem Flügel oder rechts oder links oder hinter der Spitze oder vorne. Der ist jetzt eigentlich vorne gesetzt und ich glaube, die Rotation tut tatsächlich dem Verein ganz gut oder den Spielern ganz gut, weil ja, eben viele Spieler jetzt Einsatzzeiten bekommen. Und vor allen Dingen darf vielleicht noch hervorheben die Leistung von Arda Güller, den Xabi Alonso dort richtig stark eingebaut hat. Der ist im Moment zu seinem Go-To-Guy, unwahrscheinlich stark im letzten Pass spielen kann, unwahrscheinlich torgefährlich auch ist und der im Moment richtig, richtig viel Spielzeit bekommt und das auch richtig stark macht. Und auch wenn Bellingham dann irgendwann wieder zurückkommt, kann ich mir schon vorstellen, dass nach wie vor der Türke doch auf seine, ja, viel Spielzeiten kommen wird. Und einen Top-Transfer möchte ich vielleicht noch hervorheben bei Real Madrid, der sehr gelungen war, wo ich mich auch gewundert habe, dass da andere Teams nicht schneller waren oder auch mit eingegriffen haben. Das war die Verpflichtung vom Innenverteidiger, Dejan Houssen, der holländischer Spanier, der von Bournemouth kam, glaube ich, für eine fixe Ablösung von 40 Millionen. Und das war schon ein Schnapper, wenn man die heutigen Transferpreise so sieht. Der ist 22, der ist inzwischen Nationalspieler. Der kommt hier aus der Gegend, der ist in Marbella aufgewachsen, hat beim FC Malaga die Jugendakademie durchlaufen, ist aber mit 16, glaube ich, schon zur Juve, hat dann bei Rom und der Mourinho so seinen Durchbruch in Anführungszeichen geschafft, hat bei Bournemouth, glaube ich, überragend gespielt, Chris. Du hast ihn ja auch gesehen, die zwei Saisons, wo er da war. Und ist jetzt bei Real Madrid sofort Innenverteidiger, Stammspieler, hat einen wahnsinnig starken Antritt und einen starken Pass nach vorne. Macht natürlich noch ein paar Fehler. Ich glaube, der ist jetzt immer noch erst 22, aber spielt trotzdem schon sehr abgezockt. Und ich glaube, das ist einer der Königstransfers, ohne dass er natürlich den großen Namen hat. Aber ich glaube, der steht Real Madrid richtig gut zu Gesicht. Antonio Rüdiger hat sich davon auch schon überzeugen müssen. Der ist nämlich im Moment eigentlich nur Innenverteidiger Nummer 3. Und ja, also Real Madrid muss ich sagen, hat viel richtig gemacht. Und die ganzen königlichen Fans sind eigentlich jetzt wieder so ein bisschen aufgewacht, aus der Angelotti Letagui, die so ein bisschen über dem Verein geschwebt ist die letzten Jahre.
Ach Mensch, dabei war doch Angelotti eins der, der die Fessin gelöst hat. Und jetzt wird er selbst der Letagui bezichtigt. Und die Frage ist natürlich, ist nicht jeder Transfer zur Real ein Königstransfer. Aber das müssen wir mal wannanders diskutieren, wenn du mehr Zeit hast. Und dann haben wir noch einen anderen Evergreen. Also wir haben jetzt über den einen Evergreen gesprochen, Real Madrid. Jetzt nicht so überraschend, dass wir über die sprechen im La Liga-Segment. Und du willst auch noch über Schiedsrichter sprechen. So richtig überrascht mich das auch nicht. Aber was ist denn der aktuelle Anlass?
Also das spanische Schiedsrichter-Wesen ist schon echt, also es ist echt schon der harte Nuss in der ersten Liga, aber auch in der zweiten Liga, die ich ja relativ viel verfolge, katastrophal teilweise. Wir hatten jetzt am Wochenende einen Schiedsrichter-Pfiff, der viel Aufregung gesorgt hat. Das war beim Spiel von Real Madrid bei Real Sociedad San Sebastian, wo eben genannter Dejan Huyssen oder Haussen einen Spieler am Durchlaufen gehindert hat und der Schiedsrichter ihm sofort rot gezeigt hat, wobei auf seiner Höhe auch der andere Innenverteidiger eher militär noch war und der Spieler auch nicht allein aufs Tor zugelaufen ist, sondern eigentlich eher so auf dem rechten Flügel draußen war. Und das kann man eigentlich nicht wirklich rot geben. Also ich war jetzt nicht unerfreut, weil wenn Real Madrid mal einen reinkriegt, kommt der auch nicht so oft vor. Aber nein, rein legal war die Aktion eigentlich nicht und dass der der Waren nicht eingegriffen hat, war schon sehr bizarr. Es ist aber auch so zum Beispiel in Spanien, dass der Waren mal komplett ausfällt und gar nicht funktioniert, wie zum Beispiel beim Spiel Rayo Vallecano gegen Barcelona. Und da hat sich dann zum Beispiel Laminia mal einfach in einem Strafraum fallen lassen. Der Schiedsrichter hat sofort auf 11 Meter entschieden. Es war klar im Fernsehen zu sehen, dass es eine krasse Schwalbe war, dass kein Körperkontakt stattfand. Oder zumindest nicht 11 Meter würdig. Aber es gab halt keinen Wahr. Dann konnte man natürlich an der Entscheidung auch nicht rütteln.
Aber wusste ja mal das. Also war das bekannt, dass es da keinen Wahr gibt?
Da bin ich mir jetzt gar nicht so sicher, ob das bekannt war. Ich glaube, das ist erst während des Spiels ein bisschen aufgefallen.
Das hat er gespürt.
Aber er geht ja oft mit dem Strafraum zu Fall. Also da mache ich immer gar keinen Vorwurf. Also es war schon ein bisschen Kontakt da, aber es war nie und immer ein Elfmeter. Aber da gibt es halt einfach keinen Wahr. Dann ist es halt so. Und naja, also wie gesagt, das spanische Schiedsrichterwesen ist nach wie vor sehr strittig. Die Kommunikation mit den Spielern ist auch immer sehr oder zum Großteil sehr unschön. Da wird immer von oben rab auf die Spieler gesprochen. Und die Spieler können das natürlich dann nicht nachvollziehen, vor allem wenn die Leistung der Schiedsrichter auch nicht stimmt. Und das ist eine Entwicklung, die sich auch nicht bessert in den vergangenen Jahren, sondern eigentlich immer gruseliger wird. Und was auch nicht dazu führt, dass der Wert der Liga oder die Spiele, die man von der Liga sieht, dann besser wird, weil der Schiedsrichter schon einen großen Anteil hat an so einer Spielentwicklung.
Kein schönes Thema, aber gut, wird uns auch mit begleiten. Fabian, vielen, vielen Dank, dass du das möglich gemacht hast. Wir verabschieden dich und bis bald mal wieder hier im Rasenfunk.
Bis bald und viel Spaß noch.
Danke. Und wir machen weiter. Chris, du hast gerade sehr genickt, als es um Hosen ging und seine Zeit bei Bournemouth. Wir wollen uns aber nicht über Bournemouth sprechen, sondern du hast uns einen anderen, ganz unbekannten Club mitgebracht. Du stellst die Frage, ist der– ich versuche es hier richtig, wie spricht man die aus– FC Leiberpool noch zu stoppen. Ich hoffe, ich habe es jetzt richtig gesagt.
Fast, fast. Wenn man nicht so viel Premier League intensiv verfolgt hat und einfach nur mitbekommt, 500 Millionen als am Team der Meister ausgegeben, vier Siege in den ersten vier Spielen, dabei mit den engsten Verfolger ausgeschaltet, ist der FC Leiberpool noch zu bremsen, wird man sich da fragen. Aber wenn man ein bisschen genauer hinschaut, sind die Rats noch gar nicht so einschüchtern und haben auch eine ordentliche Portion Duesel bisher gehabt. Weil erstmals in der Premier League-Geschichte hat ein Team jetzt in vier aufeinander folgenden Spielen in den letzten zehn Minuten den Siegtreffer erzielt. Und man hat schon jetzt mehr Tore in der Nachspielzeit erzielt oder ab der 90. erzielt als in der letzten Saison. Und ja, gestern bei Champions League, da hat sich der Trend übrigens auch fortgesetzt.
Und die Million hat rot gesehen. Ich weiß gar nicht, was da los war.
Also ganz komisch. Ja, also wir kennen ja auch den Bayern-Dusel von damals noch. Und das war ja oftmals so, dass das sich am Ende dann die Qualität durchsetzt, dass man ein Gegner halt so lange bearbeitet, bis er Fehler macht und einbricht. Das spielt da auch rein. Gar keine Frage. Aber trotzdem, wenn man sich die Spiele genau ansieht, da ist nicht alles Gold, was glänzt. Liverpool hat die größte Expected Points über Performance der Premier League. Das sind schon über fünf Punkte über Wert nach vier Spielen.
Krass bei zwölf Punkten insgesamt.
Genau. Das ist mit ordentlichem Abstand Platz eins. Und in allen vier Spielen hat man schon Schwächen offenbart, die es ehrlich gesagt auch schon in der Vorseason gab. Sprich im defensiven Umschaltspiel, das war jetzt beim ersten Spiel gegen Bournemouth. Man hat auch übrigens jetzt schon in fünf Pflichtspielen dreimal 1-2 zu null verspielt. Da sieht man, dass es da defensiv noch etwas hapert. Also wie gesagt, defensives Umschaltspiel. Es gibt auch noch Wackel in der Verteidigung. Und ja, gegen Arsenal und gegen Burnley hat man auch gesehen, dass im Offensivspiel auch noch nicht alles klickt. Florian Wirtz ist noch nicht ganz angekommen. Wird mich jetzt aber auch da klar positionieren und mich von dem Wirtz-Bashing distanzieren, weil das halte ich nach ein paar Spielen in einem fremden Land immer für ein bisschen schwierig. Der kann auch ankommen. Aber man sieht, es gibt noch Schwächen. Und man sieht auch, dass diese Mannschaften mehr Schwächen hat, als man nach diesen Ausgaben vielleicht vermuten will.
Aber ist das nicht eigentlich klar, gerade wenn du so spät wichtige Spieler wie dann Isaac zum Beispiel auch mit dazu holst, dass es eben ein bisschen dauert? Und man sieht es ja auch an Florian Wirtz. Also es ist natürlich schon interessant zu sehen, dass er Krämpfe hat im Spiel gegen Arsenal und deswegen ausgewechselt werden muss. Es ist noch interessanter, dass Arne Slot das nicht nur sagt, sondern fast so ein bisschen zu fiesant fand ich kommentiert, so nach dem Motto, ja, herzlich willkommen in der Premier League. Auf der anderen Seite habe ich aber auch eine Statistik gelesen, dass niemand so viele Sprints angezogen hat von Offensivspielern, als eben Florian Wirtz runtergerechnet auf seine Spielzeit. Also eigentlich ja klar, dass es nicht nur jeder Spieler für sich ankommen muss, sondern dass sich ja auch dieses Team noch so finden muss, oder?
Absolut und dementsprechend möchte ich auch klar betonen, Liverpool ist auch nach wie vor mit Top-Favorit auf die Meisterschaft. Und ich kann mir auch vorstellen, dass es irgendwann auch vorne klickt, gerade vorne. Gleichzeitig sind da wie gesagt auch Fehler oder Probleme, die es letzte Saison schon gab. Und eins muss man da auch festhalten, Liverpool war letzte Saison hochverdienter Meister, ein absolut würdiger Meister. Aber das war jetzt nicht der beeindruckendste Meister der letzten 20 Jahre. Also die 84 Punkte am Ende, die hätten nur zweimal in den letzten 20 Jahren auch zum Titel gereicht. Klar, am Ende hat man ein bisschen Tempo runtergenommen. Versteh ich. Aber man hat auch gesehen, Liverpool war nicht unschlagbar. Und da hat man schon so ein bisschen davon profitiert, dass City und Arsenal absolute solchen Jahre hatten. Nichtsdestotrotz top Mannschaft. Und vielleicht hat man auch gerade deswegen erkannt, dass man da auf jeden Fall nochmal investieren muss, weil Arsenal und City haben investiert. Die werden dieses Jahr wahrscheinlich stärker sein. Und gleichzeitig kommen Größen wie Van Dijk, Salah, Alisson, die kommen jetzt auch ein bisschen in die Jahre. Alexander Arnold ist gegangen. Und ja, also mein Problem ist so ein bisschen, dass man vielleicht die Schwächen der Vorsaison dabei ein bisschen aus den Augen gelassen hat. Wie jetzt muss man zuschlagen, keine Frage. Eke Tike sieht super aus nach den ersten Spielen. Isaac kann ich absolut nachvollziehen. Das Weltklasse-Spieler. So eine Chance hast du selten. Und mit diesen drei Leuten hast du da die Chance auf die neue Ära bei Liverpool. Die neuen Gesichter, wenn Salah mal weg ist. Und du hast auch das Potenzial, eine der besten Offensiven Europas der letzten 20 Jahre aufzustellen. Alles richtig. Aber irgendwie habe ich das Gefühl, dass man bei Isaac das Ganze so ein bisschen auf die Spitze getrieben hat. 145 Millionen ist eine Menge Geld. Gerade wenn Eke Tike funktioniert, was man schon gesehen hat. Und wenn man halt sieht, dass es da durchaus noch Baustellen gibt. Man darf jetzt auch nicht vergessen, du hast jetzt zwei Top-Stürmer gekauft für 145. Und ich glaube, bei der Eke Tike waren es 80, 90 rum. Und nur einer wird auf seiner idealen Position spielen. Das ist Fakt. Sobald einer von den beiden auf den Flügel spielt, ist er nicht mehr derselbe Spieler und dementsprechend noch weniger wert. So, hättest du das Geld jetzt vielleicht lieber auf der 6 ausgegeben, wo du eigentlich nur Grafenberg derzeit hast und trotzdem noch Schwächen hast, wie gesagt, 3 x 2 zu 0 verspielt. Hättest du das nicht vielleicht lieber ein bisschen in die Innenverteidigung investiert, wo Van Dijk zwar spielt, als wäre er 24, aber eigentlich 34 ist? Da werden Verletzungen dazukommen. Das war letzte Saison, ging es gut, das geht nicht immer gut. Klar, der Wechsel von Gey ist am Deadline, der geplatzt. Zeigt mir aber auch, dass da die Priorisierung vielleicht nicht die Beste war. Conat T schwankt ab und zu. Also, sobald einer der beiden da ausfällt und einen schlechten Tag hat, wird es dünn und auch, was die Tiefe angeht. Salah ist auch 33, dahinter hast du einen 17-Jährigen. Und Chiesa als mit die besten Optionen. Und Chiesa ist nicht mal für die Champions League registriert.
Aber der bringt immerhin die Vibes mit. Er ist jetzt schon Publikumslieferin.
Das stimmt, das stimmt. Und er kann auch in der Premier League spielen, immerhin. Nein, aber man sieht, dass da, wie gesagt, alles eine Top-Mannschaft will ich auch gar nicht irgendwie mindern. Aber man erkennt, dass da durchaus Risse im Fundament sind. Und ich habe einfach nur das Gefühl, nach diesen Ausgaben im Sommer hat man Liverpool in vielerorts schon vorzeitig zur Meisterschaft gratuliert. Und das wäre meiner Meinung nach deutlich zu freilich.
Ich wundere mich ein bisschen, dass der Name Giovanni Lyoni jetzt gar nicht gefallen ist. Der kam ja auch. Christian, könnte der vielleicht, also jetzt der andere Christian, der italienische Christian, könnte das vielleicht die Lösung in der Innenverteidigung sein. 18 Jahre ist er ja erst jung.
Genau, das wollte ich eh kurz, ob er die Lösung sein kann. Also du hast gesagt, er ist 18, also da würde ich jetzt mal ganz langsam vorgehen. Aber wie Chris hier richtig gesagt, ich finde auch, also in der Innenverteidigung sind sie echt ziemlich dünn besetzt. Also wenn Van Dijk oder Konaté was passiert, ich glaube im Moment, Chris korrigiere mich, ist Lyoni die Nummer 4. Der junge Mann ist halt 18 und hat bis jetzt, glaube ich, 20 Serie A Spiele gemacht. Also ja, für das eben, dass sie so wahnsinnig viel Geld in die Hand genommen haben und eben auf anderen Positionen herausragend mehrfach besetzt sind. Ja, bin ich mal, also ist es logisch zu wünschen, dass da nichts passiert, ist ja klar. Und für Lyoni selbst, glaube ich, ist es eine riesen Chance, weil bei den vielen Spielen, die Liverpool hat, alle drei Tage, wir wissen ja auch in England, durch die zusätzlichen Pokalwettbewerbe, gibt es ja noch mehr Spiele. Also ich muss sagen, am Anfang dachte ich mir, oh, warum geht er jetzt da hin? Also jetzt einfach, ich hätte am Anfang gehofft, Liverpool kauft ihn, aber lässt ihn vielleicht noch eine Saison in Parma, um einfach noch ein Jahr mehr zu geben, wo er Stammspieler ist. Aber jetzt eben, als ich mir dann den Kader von Liverpool in der Defensive angeschaut habe, ich glaube, der wird das ein oder andere Spiel bekommen, weil defensiv, innenverteidigungsmäßig, es gar nicht so tief ist. Und Talent hat er, ja.
Genau, das ist der Punkt. Er ist halt sehr jung. Er könnte der weltbeste Innenverteidiger werden. Das will ich gar nicht abstreiten. Aber es wird Wachstumsprobleme geben, sagen wir es mal so. Und das ist nämlich eben der Unterschied. Jetzt beispielsweise, wenn man zu Arsenal blickt, die zweite Elf, das ist ja absurd. Also ich habe mir das jetzt mal gerade angeschaut nebenher. Sie hatten ja jetzt schon die ersten Spieltage Probleme. Saliba verletzt, Saka verletzt, Ödegard verletzt, Harbertz verletzt. Und trotzdem hast du da eigentlich keinen großen Einbruch mehr gesehen. Das war letzte Saison noch ganz anders. Und da hast du in der zweiten Elf mittlerweile ein Martinelli, ein Madueke, ein Hincapié, ein Mosquera, ein Merino. Das ist schon mehr als nur ordentlich. Und wenn ich mir einfach so eine lange Spielzeit anschaue mit über 50 Pflichtspielen und wenn man gerade als Liverpool wirklich auf ältere Leute sich verlassen muss, kann ich mir vorstellen, dass am Ende die Mannschaft mit der besseren Tiefe sich durchsetzen wird. Kann natürlich alles ganz anders kommen, will ich gar nicht sagen. Aber ich habe einfach ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass Liverpool dann vielleicht einen Tick zu naiv agiert hat im Sommer.
Oder haben Sie vielleicht jemanden in Ihren Jugend-Teams, bei dem Sie sagen, okay, dem wollen wir jetzt auch nicht die Möglichkeit auf fünf bis zehn Start-F-Einsätze verbauen? Also Mara Nallo ist der Kapitän der U19 und spielt auch bei der U21. Aber ich will es nicht so tun, als ob ich irgendetwas über ihn wusste, außer sein Namen. Ich weiß nicht, ob du da mehr zu sagen kannst.
Nein, sie haben sehr viele gute Talente. Das ist absolut korrekt. Aber wenn du eben um mehrere Titel spielen willst, kannst du dich nicht auf diese Jungen verlassen. Wenn sie durchbrechen, alles super, dann wird man ihnen auch die Möglichkeiten geben. Das ist bei Rasenau übrigens ähnlich mit Daumen, der jetzt 15 ist, hat jetzt auch schon ein paar Einsätze bekommen. Also die Qualität setze ich dann durch. Aber in eine Saison zu gehen und von einem 17-Jährigen, von einem 18-Jährigen zu erwarten, dass sie dann wirklich auch tragende Rollen spielen können, ist meines Erachtens ein Tick naiv. Da muss man schon erfahrene Leute auch parat haben, gerade wenn sie über einen längeren Zeitraum spielen, gerade wenn sie zum ersten Mal auswärts gegen City spielen, wenn sie zum ersten Mal in der Champions League gegen Barca spielen, etc., pp. Also da weißt du nicht, wie ein junger Spieler damit umgeht. Das ist halt auch so. Und man merkt auch oft bei jüngeren Spielern, dass das auch neue körperliche Umstände für sie sind. Da kommt es schneller mal zu muskulären Verletzungen, weil die Intensität einfach höher ist. Und sich dann nur auf solche Spieler zu verlassen, kann auch nach hinten losgehen.
Gut. Ich meine, es hängt wahrscheinlich auch sehr viel damit zusammen mit Verletzungsglück und Verletzungspech. Du kannst zu jemandem, glaube ich, einfach mal in der Premier League gegen ein Team vom Tabellenende auflaufen lassen. Aber du willst es eben nicht gegen Alonso's Real Madrid im Champions League-Halbfinale. Aber das ist ja klar. Aber auf jeden Fall interessante Perspektive auf Liverpool, die ich so auch jetzt noch nicht so oft gelesen habe, ehrlich gesagt. Vielen Dank dafür. Dann wollen wir mal in die Serie A blicken. Und Christian darf uns noch ein bisschen was erzählen zu Juve. Denn da gab es einige bemerkenswerte Ergebnisse. Ja, unter anderem das 4 zu 4 gegen den BVB haben alle mitbekommen. Aber wenn du mir hier schon in mein Dokument Spektakel Juve reinschreibst, dann scheint das ja nicht das einzige solches Ergebnis gewesen zu sein. Oder geht es jetzt um die Schlussphase gegen Dortmund?
Ne, drei Tage davor gab es ein 4-3 gegen Inter im Derby d'Italia. Ach, das stimmt richtig.
Da haben wir uns ja sogar noch getroffen.
Bei Juve waren… Entschuldigung. Ja, also das war äußerst spektakulär. Ich möchte ganz kurz nur, das Thema Dean Haussen können wir jetzt perfekt abrunden, weil es da wunderbar reinpasst. Juve waren nämlich die, die vor einem Jahr sich von Haussen getrennt haben für knapp 20 Millionen Euro, wo man jetzt logisch komplett den Kopf schütteln kann. Und das tun bei Juve logischerweise auch viele. Aber das schließt sich mit dem an, Max, was du vorhin gesagt hast. Haussen war intern und da war jeder Euro, den sie da bekommen haben, war einer, den sie direkt in die Wirtschaftsbücher schreiben konnten. Und sie dachten, dass sie das Geld brauchen für andere Transfers. Das ist nicht ausgegangen, aufgegangen, aber nur so viel. Da können wir das Thema Haussen perfekt abrunden. Und noch ein Ding zur Summe, weil es in Italien dann schon sehr genau beobachtet wurde. Also in Italien hieß es, Real hat schon 60 Millionen bezahlt. Also jetzt so ganz billig war er dann doch nicht, weil Juve hatte da eine 10-prozentige Weiterverkaufsbeteiligung. Also Juve hat nochmal 6 Millionen bekommen. Aber lange Rede, kurzer Sinn, war logisch jetzt gesehen, sportlich gesehen, sehr schlecht von Juve, dass sie sich frühzeitig von Haussen getrennt haben. Denn, und jetzt kriegen wir einen Bogen zur Aktualität, wenn ich mir denken würde, dass heute bei Juve Haussen neben Bremer spielt in der Innenverteidiger, dann würde ich mal sagen, wäre Juve für die nächsten Jahre im Innenverteidiger-Part relativ gut aufgestellt. Ja, aber kommen wir zur Aktualität. 4-4 gegen Dortmund, glaube ich, die meisten mitbekommen. 4-3 gegen Inter, eben drei Tage davor. Also, jetzt kann man logisch sagen, Juve 7 Gegentore da kassiert, das stimmt, sehr ungewöhnlich. Aber sie haben halt auch 8 gemacht gegen zwei gute oder sehr gute Teams. Und vor allen Dingen, es waren ja extreme Comebacks dabei. Also, gegen Dortmund lagen sie bis zur 94. Zweifel hinten und haben noch gepunktet. Und gegen Inter lagen sie bis zur 82. Zweidreizurück und haben das Spieler noch komplett gedreht und gewonnen. Also, da ist irgendwie so ein bisschen frischer Wind drin. Da kann man auch gleich zur Offensive, weil da hat sich eben einiges getan. Also, Juve hat ja aus Frankreich Jonathan David von Lille Ablöse frei geholt, der, glaube ich, das weiß Jakob logischerweise nur allzu gut, der letzten Jahr sehr verlässlich gescord hat. Haben am letzten Transfertag auch noch Obandar aus Leipzig geholt. Das war so ein bisschen, ja, sage ich mal, die B-Variante, weil Juve den ganzen Sommer versucht, noch Kolo Muay Ni wieder zu holen. Der war ja letztes Jahr auf Live-Basis bei Juve aus PSG. Juve hat es auch über den Sommer probiert, da irgendwie wieder zumindest nicht eine Kaufpflicht zu integrieren, aber das wollte dann PSG nicht mehr. Und als es dann klar war, okay, das klappt nicht, dann sind sie auf Opendar umgeschwenkt. Und der Name, der jetzt auch das perfekte eigentlich Geschichte jetzt mit Dortmund, man muss halt über Vlaovic sprechen. Denn Vlaovic hat jetzt an den ersten vier Spielen, Pflichtspielen vier Tore für Juve gemacht. Jetzt kann man meinen, ja, das wäre ja an sich ganz normal. Er ist ja auch der Neuner von Juve. Ja, der Punkt ist nur der, dass Vlaovic eigentlich auch über den Sommer mehr oder weniger Juve auch schon einiges probiert hat, um sich von Vlaovic zu trennen. Das liegt zur Erläuterung nicht unbedingt nur an den sportlichen Qualitäten von Vlaovic, sondern vielmehr an den finanziellen Rahmenbedingungen. Denn Vlaovic hat einen sehr hoch dotierten Vertrag vor einigen Jahren bei Juve unterschrieben, als er aus Florenz kam, der sich jedes Jahr gesteigert hat. Und diese Saison, das ist jetzt sein letztes Vertragsjahr, also er geht in sein letztes Vertragsjahr, da kommen in den Sommer also Ablöse frei. Verdient Vlaovic– Achtung– 12 Millionen Netto. Das heißt, Brutto wären wir da bei 24. Und das ist mit Abstand das höchste Gehalt in der Serie A. Also da kommt kein Lautaro dran, da sind alle anderen 1, 2 Millionen weg. Und für die 12 Millionen Netto, die er jetzt verdient, hat er die letzten zwei Jahre nicht performt. Also Vlaovic– vielleicht erinnere ich mich noch ein paar– vor 3, 4 Jahren, würde ich sagen, nach Haarland vielleicht der große Neuner Hoffnung Europas und die letzten 1, 2 Jahren einmal unter Allegri, dann auch zuletzt unter Thiago Motta. Das hat nicht wirklich funktioniert. Er saß viel auf der Bank und jetzt eben war dann dieser Punkt, es hat sich abgezeichnet, dass er seinen Vertrag wohl nicht verlängern wird. Und dann hat Juve halt versucht, sich A, nochmal ablöse, durch einen Transfer zu generieren und B, sich seines riesigen Gehalts halt einfach zu entledigen. Denn nochmal 12 Millionen Netto bedeuten für Juve-Seite 24 ungefähr brutto. Das ist ein ordentlicher Patzengeld. Das hat alles nicht geklappt im Sommer, weil auch Lovic logischerweise nur Angebote überhaupt in Sicht genommen hat, die vielleicht auf dem Vertragsniveau lagen. Die kamen für ihn nicht. Und jetzt ist er geblieben und jetzt muss man ihn aber richtig hoch anrechnen. Er hat all diese vier Tore, also zwei gegen Dortmund, eins gegen Parma und eins gegen Genoa. Das war siegentscheidend von der Bank kommend geschossen. Also er hat verstanden oder Tudor hat ihm klargemacht, im Moment bist du nicht meine erste Wahl, weil eben David da ist, weil Opendar ist, weil Lidlis gesetzt ist, weil Juve in der Tiefe, in der Offensive wirklich nachgelegt hat. Und Lovic nimmt das aber an, kommt da rein, bringt jedes Mal Energie und gegen Dortmund bereitet er auch noch das 4-4 vor. Also, ich glaube, in der NBA würde man reden, erst in seinem Contract hier. Und so spielt er im Moment. Denn logischerweise geht es für ihn halt auch darum, seinen Marktwert einfach hochzuhalten, um nächstes Jahr im Idealfall ablösefrei, wo immer dann auch wieder einen fetten Vertrag zu unterschreiben. Aber um das Thema eben abzurunden, die Offensive bei Juve eben Vlaović, Opendar, David, Yildiz dahinter, Yildiz überragend, dass er so einen Start hat. Ich glaube, dass wird das Yildiz-Jahr. Also, wer das Tor gegen Dortmund gesehen hat, da wurden bei Juve einige Del Piero-Vibes an denen wurde, an die wurde erinnert, gegen Inter hat er getroffen. Also schultert wirklich diese Offensive. Also, um es auf den Punkt zu bringen, wir werden jetzt bei Juve nicht jede Woche 4-4, sondern 4-3 sehen. Ich glaube, das waren jetzt schon erstmal eher Ausnahmen, diese zwei Spieler. Aber es zeigt, dass sie offensiv wirklich nachgelegt haben. Letzter Name noch, Jakob kennt ihn auch, Zej Grova kam auch von Lille. Der hat ein bisschen Trainingsrückstand, aber das ist echt, glaube ich, auch ein richtig guter Zocker, der dir einfach im letzten Drittel da so ein paar ganz, ganz ungeplante Momente kreieren kann. Also die Offensive bei Juve in diesem Jahr deutlich tiefer.
Und du hast jetzt Igor Tudor schon erwähnt, das war ja noch so eine nette Nebengeschichte, dass sich ausgerechnet zwei Protagonisten von dem HSV-Juve 4-4-Spiel auf den Trainerbänken begegnet sind, eben Nico Kovac auf der einen Seite und Igor Tudor auf der anderen Seite. Was ist denn zu ihm zu sagen? Denn in der Vergangenheit war ja Juve-Trainer-Sein jetzt nicht unbedingt die langfristigste Geschichte.
Ja, Tudor, also Tudor zur Erinnerung kam ja letztes Jahr im März, sozusagen, weil das Projekt Jagomod dann überhaupt nicht funktioniert hat. Dann hat er eben sein einziges Saisonziel erreicht, nämlich er hat Juve in die Champions League gebracht. Das war die einzige Aufgabe, die er mitbekommen hatte und die hat er hinbekommen. Er hat in den letzten, glaube ich, 13 Spielen nur noch eins verloren und hat Juve eben dahin gebracht. Und müssen wir jetzt auch nicht groß drumherum reden, Juve hat schon auch ein bisschen die Fühler im Sommer nach anderen Trainern ein bisschen ausgestreckt. Es hieß auch am Ende noch mal bei Gasparini, dass wir es dann noch mal probiert hätten. Aber am Ende ist er geblieben und er macht es sehr solide. Also tue doch zur Erinnerung vielleicht, hat nicht jeder auf dem Schirm langjähriger Spieler bei Juve. Also er kennt den Verein in- und auswendig. Der war zu den Zidane-Zeiten, zu den Del Piero-Zeiten, zu den Nedved-Zeiten Spieler bei Juve, also bei den ganz großen Zeiten. Spricht auch immer wieder davon auf Pressekonferenzen. Du merkst, der will auch diese JuvedNA sozusagen. Also die lebt er wirklich, das muss man dem wirklich abnehmen. Und das ist gar nicht so unwichtig. Denn Juve ist immer noch ein relativ junges Team. Letztes Jahr waren es jetzt zwei jüngste Team der Serie A. Da hätten wahrscheinlich auch nicht viele bei Juve gedacht. Dieses Jahr haben sie auch, ich glaube gegen Dortmund hatten sie einen Altersschnitt von 24,9. Also da ist schon noch relativ viel Jugendlichkeit dabei. Und eben die großen Namen, die Bonucci, die Chiellinis, die Pirlos, die Buffons, die sind ja alle nicht mehr da, die diese JuvedNA hatten. Deswegen ist es, glaube ich, schon wichtig, dass mit Tudor einer jetzt auch der Trainerbank ist, der weiß, was es heißt, bei Juve Trainer zu sein, der den Druck kennt, die Erwartungshaltung bei Juve. Und dementsprechend, das macht er bisher richtig gut. In der Liga drei Spiele, drei Siege. Er ist sehr ruhig, das ist keiner, das Scheinwerferlicht sucht. Der macht seine Sachen, stellt sich gar nicht groß in den Mittelpunkt. Und wie gesagt, dieses 4-3-4-4, das werden wir jetzt nicht die nächsten Wochen, jede Woche sehen. Denn Tudo ist schon auch einer, das ist auch hohes Pressing, intensives Spiel. Da ist die Defensive, der ist schon auch eine wichtige Rolle zugetan. Aber eben wie gesagt, er hat jetzt wahnsinnig viel offensives Potenzial. Konzessau haben wir noch nicht genannt, den haben sie auch noch. Der hat jetzt gegen Dortmund mit muskulären Problemen gefehlt. Also allein so in diesem, also so sein Grundsystem ist dieses 3-4-2-1, also zwei halbe Offensive plus einen Stürmer. Also allein Wendu Wlauowicz, Openda, David, Yildiz, Segrova, Konzessau. Das ist schon eine gewisse individuelle Qualität. Und wenn er die weiterhin auf die Straße bringt, dann scheint sich da was sehr Gutes zu finden.
Aber wirklich. Und dieses Zusammentreffen mit Niko Kovac, der ja auch geholt wurde, erst mal nur mit dem Ziel, die Champions League zu erreichen, und jetzt auch eben länger bleiben darf und vielleicht eben auch unterschätzt wird, weil die Ergebnisse sind ja da und da kann man ja auch dieses 4-4 mit reinnehmen. Klar, du kannst es auch negativ erzählen, ein 4-2 noch weggeworfen. Aber wenn man vor dem Spiel gesagt hätte, ihr haltet bei Juve sehr, sehr gut mit und werdet führen und am Ende nehmt ihr einen Punkt mit, hätten wahrscheinlich viele BVB-Fans gesagt, gekauft, alles gut. Also vielleicht ja auch einer der unterschätzten Trainer. Sehr schön diese Parallelen. Dann kommen wir jetzt in unsere schnellere Runde. Jakob, du durftest ganz lange nichts mehr sagen, obwohl immer wieder Spielernamen von ehemaligen Ligue 1-Spielern gefallen sind. Das ist übrigens das Schicksal, wenn man hier für die Ligue 1 mit dabei ist. Du kennst jeden Spieler, du könntest zu allem noch mal eine Background-Story erzählen. Nicht immer haben wir Zeit dafür. Also was hast du uns denn noch mitgebracht oder willst du uns noch irgendwelches Wissen auffüllen? Ich habe dich manchmal so leicht zucken sehen.
Nee, das passt schon. Ich habe als nächstes Thema noch Olympique Marseille mitgebracht und damit so ein bisschen den nächsten Chaos Club, kann man glaube ich sagen, aus Frankreich. Obwohl die letzte Saison eigentlich sportlich ganz okay lief. Man hat zwar nicht wirklich in den Titelkampf eingreifen können. Paris Saint-Germain ist ja sehr, sehr früh Meister geworden und das stand dann auch sehr lange schon fest. Und man hatte durchaus auch ein paar Probleme, ist aber am Ende dann doch relativ klar zweiter geworden, war auch über weite Strecken eigentlich auch das zweitbeste Team in Frankreich. Allerdings gab es auch in der letzten Saison schon Unruhe. Unter anderem gab es zum Saisonende ein wochenlanges Trainingslager, was Roberto de Serbi, der Trainer, angeordnet hatte, wo dann Marseille immer aus dem Trainingslager zu den Spielen gefahren ist, um dann wieder ins Trainingslager zu gehen. Einfach weil der Serbi meinte, ja, das ist besser, wenn ich die Mannschaft hier eigentlich den ganzen Tag vor Ort habe. Hat natürlich auch teilweise für Unverständnis gesorgt und so weiter und so fort. Allgemein, act de Serbi immer wieder an. Man kennt das ja auch schon aus seiner Zeit bei Brighton, dass er jetzt, glaube ich, nicht der leichteste Charakter ist. Und dann war eigentlich gar nicht unbedingt geplant, dass man jetzt im Sommer so einen Riesen-Kader-Umbruch macht. Es ist dann aber, wie es auch anders sein sollte, bei Marseille letztendlich doch ganz anders gekommen. Man hat erst nicht so viele Leistungsträger abgegeben. Luis Henrique ist weggegangen. Man hat noch ein paar, ja nicht unbedingt, Stammspieler abgegeben mit Merlin, Rongier, Benassier. Aber dann kam natürlich nach dem ersten Spieltag der Paukenschlag, dass nämlich in der Kabine, da wurde, um das vorwegzunehmen, 1 zu 0 verloren gegen Stadtrennen, obwohl man fast 80 Minuten in Überzahl war. Und da viele Chancen vergeben hat, auch nicht so richtig gut gespielt hat und sich dann kurz vor Schluss das Tor gefangen hat. Und dann gab es aber in der Kabine am ersten Spieltag richtig Unruhe. Jonathan Rowe und Adrian Rabiot sind da handfest aneinandergeraten. Bezüglich der Stufe der Brutalität gibt es da von allen Seiten irgendwie andere Aussagen. Also der Serbi hat davon gesprochen, dass er sowas noch nie gesehen hätte in seinem ganzen Leben. Und andererseits hat man aber auch von Veronique Rabiot, der ja immer sehr meinungsstarken Mutter von Adrian Rabiot gehört, dass ja keiner verletzt gewesen sei, keiner geblutet hätte und ist deswegen ja auch so schlimm gewesen.
Das muss ich beides nicht widersprechen, ehrlich gesagt.
Genau. Aber da gab es dann von allen Seiten unterschiedliche Aussagen zu. Bei Jonathan Rowe war relativ schnell klar, also beide Spieler wurden erstmal suspendiert. Bei Jonathan Rowe war sehr schnell klar, dass er auch gehen soll, obwohl Marseille ihn auch diesen Sommer erst fest verpflichtet hatte, nachdem er vorher von Norwich ausgeliehen war. Und da stand dann auch recht schnell fest, dass er geht zu Bologna in die Serie A für 17 Millionen. Und bei Adrian Rabiot war es erst ein bisschen hin und her. Es gab dann auch zu hören, dass de Serbi eigentlich ihn gerne behalten würde, trotz des ganzen Theaters. Weil, man muss das sagen, Rabiot war letzte Saison eigentlich der Schlüsselspieler bei Marseille im zentral-offensiven Mittelfeld. Er zählte auch zu den Führungsspielern im Kader, oder zählte zu den Führungsspielern im Kader. Aber letztendlich hat man dann nicht die Basis dafür gesehen, dass er wirklich noch weiter Bestandteil dieser Mannschaft sein kann, sodass er jetzt letztendlich auch zu Milan gegangen ist. Und das führte dann auf der anderen Seite dazu, dass man letztendlich jetzt doch einen riesigen Umbruch im Kader wieder hatte. Auch ein paar Spieler dann noch geholt hat kurz vor Schluss. Mit Pavard zum Beispiel von Inter auch einen durchaus bekannten Verteidiger. Man hat auch noch weitere Verteidiger geholt, sodass man jetzt teilweise auch mit einer komplett neuen Viererkette spielen könnte. Es sind jetzt so 7, 8 Neuzugänge je nach Spiel in der Startelf gewesen. Man hat Pierre-Emerick Aubameyang zurückgeholt aus Saudi-Arabien. Und ja, also dann am Deadline-Day noch Naif Agard geholt, O'Reilly von Brighton ausgeliehen, Vermehran von Leipzig ausgeliehen. Und also ist jetzt wieder letztendlich alles total neu. Dementsprechend durchwachsen war auch er der Saisonstart mit zwei Siegen, die relativ deutlich waren jeweils zu Hause und aber auch zwei Auswärtsniederlagen. Dann hat man ja auch in der Champions League schon bei Real Madrid sich phasenweise durchaus ganz gut geschlagen am Dienstag, auch wenn es in der Anfangsphase sehr wild aussah und man da sehr viel unter Druck geraten ist. Aber ja, man hat vielleicht so ein bisschen einfach durch diesen wahnsinnig bewegten Transfer so mal verpasst, sich zu konsolidieren und vielleicht jetzt den nächsten Schritt in Richtung Paris Saint-Germain zu gehen und ist stattdessen jetzt so, dass man eigentlich die Mannschaft noch mal komplett umgekrempelt hat und so wieder so ein bisschen von vorne anfangen muss.
Also viel, viel los bei Olympique, das kennen wir schon. Ich habe extra nachgeguckt. Milan hat schon gegen Bologna gespielt, Rabiot hat durchgespielt und Jonathan Rowe wurde eingewechselt in der 74. Minute. Christian, sind irgendwelche besonderen Vorkommnisse aus diesem Spiel zu berichten?
Ich würde es gerade sagen, das ist der Fun-Fact, den ich noch beitragen wollte. Also die zwei haben gleich wirklich beim ersten Spiel– sind sie aufeinander getroffen? Nein, es ist nichts passiert. Aber ja, ganz witzig, dass sie wirklich gleich in ihrem ersten Pflichtspiel für die Neumannschaften gleich aufeinander treffen. Ein Satz noch zu De Zerbi. Also De Zerbi hat gemeint, er kommt von der Straße und das stimmt. Er kommt aus nicht ganz einfachen Verhältnissen und er meinte, so etwas hätte er in der Fußballkabine noch nie erlebt. Also da war schon ein bisschen mehr los, weil ansonsten hätten die sich jetzt, glaube ich, auch nicht unbedingt von beiden Spielen getrennt. Und wie Jakob ja gesagt hat, gerade Rabiot ist ja für die unfassbar wichtig. Also wir waren alle nicht dabei, aber ich glaube, das war ein bisschen heftiger, was da vonstatten gegangen ist.
Das Einzige, was man aus Frankreich noch gehört hat, dass Rabiot seinen Vertrag, der zum Saisonende ausläuft, wohl nicht verlängern will oder wollte bisher, beziehungsweise halt seine Konditionen beibehalten wollte und Marseille hätte gerne einen günstigeren Vertrag. Und dann wurde das zum Beispiel auch Marseille von der Seite, von Spielerseite vorgeworfen, dass sie das jetzt nutzen würden sozusagen, um ihn rauszudrängen. Aber wie gesagt, ich glaube auch eher nicht, dass das so hohe Wellen geschlagen hätte, wenn das, wenn sie sich nur kurz geschubst hätten oder so.
Na ja, vielleicht kann man festhalten, so ein wochenlanges Trainingslager fürs Team-Belting ist vielleicht nicht immer das Beste. Aber wollen wir mal nicht noch mehr reininterpretieren. Das ist der eine Chaos-Club. Und damit haben wir die perfekte Überleitung zu Manchester United. Über die wollen wir auch noch sprechen. Chris, es ist immer das gleiche mit United. Und irgendwie ist es doch immer anders. Die Frage ist nur, wie lange werden wir noch über United in dieser Art sprechen müssen? Also was sind so die aktuellen Themen, die du da noch kurz ansprechen wolltest?
Ja, ich wollte gerade sagen, also es geht immer irgendwie die letzten Jahre immer um Negativrekorde. Es geht nur darum, was für ein Negativrekord es diesmal ist. Eigentlich wäre das Thema natürlich auch ein Hauptthema wert. Aber wie du gerade sagst, es wiederholt sich immer wieder. Am Sonntag, chancenlos gegen Manchester City. Das siebte Mal jetzt mit 3-Ton-Unterschied gegen Pep Guardiola verloren. Schlechtes der Saisonstart seit 1992. Pokal aus gegen einen Vierteligisten. Und das Hauptthema momentan ist natürlich Amorim als Trainer. Seit Ehrenamt hat kein Team, das noch in der Premier League ist, weniger Punkte geholt. Und das ist jetzt ein Jahr. 31 Punkte in 32 Spielen, das ist schon sehr dünn. Ja, gegen City, wenn man das Spiel nicht gesehen hat und auf die Zahlen schaut, wird man denken, ganz gut verkauft, ganz gut mitgehalten. Ein Tick mehr Ballbesitz, glaube ich sogar, mehr Kontakt im Strafraum, mehr Flanken, blablabla. Aber es war ehrlich gesagt nie wirklich knapp. Uniteds Angriff war stumpf, ideenlos, hat auch nicht viel Sinn ergeben, defensive schwach und es wirkt irgendwie so, als würde City so ein bisschen die Handbremse anziehen. Man wusste, dass man einfach mehr Qualität auf dem Platz hat. Und das ist für mich so ein bisschen das Erschreckende. Klar, es ist eigentlich nie erschreckend, wenn man gegen City spielt und weniger Qualität hat. Aber wenn man sieht, dass United in den letzten fünf Jahren eigentlich genauso viel ausgegeben hat wie City, nämlich über eine Milliarde, und dann auf den Platz schaut, dann sieht man, dass da schon viel falsch gemacht wurde. Und ich habe das Gefühl, das hat sich gerade diesen Sommer fortgesetzt. Kunja, Mbembo, das sind alles, das sind super Spieler. Aber man hat halt wieder die Aktie am höchsten Punkt gekauft. Letztes Jahr haben beide statistisch gesehen sehr überperformt, haben vor allem XG überperformt und wurden dann für über 70 Millionen gekauft. Das ist nicht die klügste Investition. Cesko kann ich irgendwo verstehen, hat ein Weltklasse-Profil, wir kennen ihn aus der Bundesliga, aber dann wieder knapp 80 Millionen hinlegen. Wenn es noch andere Baustellen gibt, kann man auch ein bisschen hinterfragen. Und wenn man dann die Mannschaft sieht, da strotzt es noch an so vielen Ecken und Enden vor Durchschnitt. Casimero wirkt meistens als ob er keine Lust hat. Ogarte zerstört, kann nicht wie mit dem Ball anfangen. Hinter Defensive taucht dann immer noch ein Schor auf, ein McGuire auf, der natürlich etwas zu sehr kritisiert wird, aber trotzdem halt nicht der Top-In-Verteidiger ist. Und beste Spieler ist noch Bruno Fernandes, der auch– und jetzt will ich keine Stammtischparolen à la Roy Keane verwenden– aber der wirklich kein typischer Kapitän und Anführer ist, meiner Meinung nach. Nur meckert, nur defensiv negativ auffällt. Und ja, also es läuft viel, viel falsch. Und am bedenklichsten ist, dass es, meiner Meinung nach, bei Amorim auch falsch läuft. Er hält stur an seinem 3-4-3 fest, obwohl er nicht den Kader dazu hat. Er hat jetzt nach der Pleide gegen City gesagt, wenn ihr meine Philosophie ändern wollt, dann müsst ihr die Menschen austauschen. Klare Ansage, dass er bei seiner Sache bleibt. Und das ist für mich das Seltsamste an der gesamten Geschichte. Es taucht ein Mason Mount auf dem Flügel auf. Du hast nicht die Leute für einen 3-4-3. Und am seltsamsten ist es, wenn man sich das Spiel gegen City anschaut. Und da hat dann dein Schiedenspieler, Dorgu war das, mehr Ballkontakt in der Box gehabt als dein Stürmer und dein Zehner. Und da sieht man schon, dass da irgendwie was falsch läuft, auch systematisch. Und die haben das Ganze wieder ganz kurz runterzubringen auf einen Satz. Ich finde einfach, United hat seit Jahren immer wieder das gleiche Problem. Du hast kein übergeordnetes Konzept. Du hast überteuerte Spieler, die nicht zum Trainer passen oder umgekehrt. Und es ändern sich eigentlich nur noch die Namen.
Es ist wirklich so. Also das, was du jetzt zu Amorim erzählt hast, das war Endphase Ten Hag. Und zwar Endphase, meine ich damit, die letzten anderthalb Jahre Ten Hag, glaube ich. Kann man ungefähr so sagen. Also das ist ja völlig… Ach, Wahnsinn. Ja, United. Wir werden, glaube ich, in der Saison noch öfter über United sprechen. Da gibt es ja immer nochmal… Du hast es ja gesagt, den neuen Tiefpunkt gibt es dann. Aber wir wollen auch positive Dinge ansprechen, beziehungsweise auch mal über Teams sprechen, bei denen es gut läuft. Und damit können wir über Napoli reden. Christian, zumindest vermute ich, dass du Positives zu sagen hast bei drei Spielen, drei Siegen in der Liga und 6 zu 1 Toren.
Ja, können wir auch direkt die Brücke bauen zu Chris, auch wieder zu United. Bei Napoli spielt ein gewisser Scott Mcdominate, der das nicht so schlecht macht seit einem Jahr und zwei Monaten. Das ist ja auch so eine Geschichte. Und es geht nicht darum, Scott Mcdominate zum größten Fußballer zu machen, keine Sorge. Aber ich glaube, das war einer, der sehr an United hing, auch vielleicht ein bisschen mehr als nur als Profi. Und es ist ja vielleicht auch so eine kleine Geschichte, dass du dich da auch von solchen Leuten trennst. Und da haben wir jetzt aber die Geschichte, Scott Mcdominate und Neapol ist funktioniert wunderbar. Max, ich wollte Neapol nur jetzt ganz kurz anreisen, über die werden wir logisch in Ruhe demnächst mal reden. Erstens mal, weil wir haben ihn noch gar nicht zur Meisterschaft gratuliert. Vergangenes Saison hatten wir ja keine Sendung mehr. Also, dass Conte und Napoli Meister geworden sind, ist ja schon was Besonderes. Und jetzt eben kommt dazu, vielleicht passen die Themen ganz gut ineinander. Die Wirtschaftlichkeit von Neapol ist richtig gut in den letzten Jahren. Neapol ist mit die wirtschaftlich stärkste, der stärkste Club in Italien. Und das führt dazu, dass die einen Transfer-Sommer hatten, der für italienische Verhältnisse wirklich alle in den Schatten gestellt hat. Also alle Inters, Juves, Milans, wie sie hießen, konnten da nicht mithalten. Denn Neapol hat zu dieser bestehenden, starken Mannschaft nochmal richtig tief in die Tiefe gegangen. Angefangen Kevin De Bruyne, logischerweise. Ich glaube, ich habe alle mitbekommen, dass der mittlerweile am Vesuv kickt. Hat gleich auch schon zweimal getroffen. Wunderbar integriert. Ja, ich glaube, über die Qualität von De Bruyne muss man nicht reden. Ja, er ist nicht mehr der Jüngste. Aber ich würde mal sagen, die ersten Spiele haben gezeigt, dass er nicht zum Urlaub machen in Italien ist. Und allein dieses Plus an Übersicht, dieses Plus an Genialität, dieses Plus an Pässe im letzten Drittel, das tut Neapel sehr gut. Dazu haben sie im Sturm jetzt noch, dass sich Lukaku ja schwer verletzt hat. Der fällt jetzt erst mal noch drei Monate aus. Haben sie einfach noch mal Heulund von United sich ausgeliehen. Der trifft gleich im ersten Spiel. Der gibt ihnen logischerweise noch mal Tiefe vorne drin. Luca, den italienischen Nationalstürmer, haben sie auch schon davor dazugeholt. Und in der Abwehr haben sie mit Bojkama einen der stärksten italienischen oder Serie A-Verteidiger der letzten zwei Jahre von Bologna geholt, der einfach auch noch mal die Tiefe verstärkt. Im Tor Milinkovic-Savic eine Eins dazugeholt zu Maret. Also im Prinzip hat Konti jetzt 2, 1a, 1b. Also Napoli hat sich wirklich noch mal in der Tiefe, in der Breite qualitativ verstärkt. Und ja, dass es so ein Start passt, da ist die Euphorie noch da. Der Bräun ist wirklich alle schwärmen von seiner ruhigen Art. Der ist überhaupt nicht hingekommen, so von wegen ich bin der König, so küst mir die Füße, sondern der fügt sich wunderbar ein. Und Mc Domines weiterhin da, Alo Podcast da, Anguissa ist da, Politano di Lorenzo. Also ich wollte nur ein bisschen kurz Lust auf Napoli machen. Wie gesagt, da reden wir dann die nächsten Wochen sicher mal in Ruhe drüber. Ich glaube, das konnte Napoli auch in der Champions League in diesem Jahr. Jetzt keine Sorge, die sind jetzt logischerweise nicht plötzlich unter den ersten acht großen Namen zu nennen. Das ist mir schon klar. Aber ich glaube, das gerade konnte, hat ja auch ein bisschen eine offene Geschichte mit der Champions League, dass Napoli in dieser Saison auch international dem ein oder anderen vermeintlich größeren paar Aufgaben stellen wird.
Vielleicht ja schon heute Abend bei Manchester City. Und man wird ja auch unter anderem zu Hause gegen Eintracht Frankfurt spielen. Da kann man noch mal genauer hingucken aus deutscher Sicht.
Champions League am Donnerstag?
Ein Satz noch, da hat…
Ich will meinen Fußball.
Ey, schlimm. Ich wollte den Leverkusen-Schwerpunkt machen und bin völlig mit den Terminen durcheinander gekommen, weil die mir alle geschrieben haben, ja, ich bin bei der Champions League. So, ja, machen wir es Donnerstag. Vielleicht habe ich am Nachmittag noch Zeit. Ja, nee, da spielen die. Ach so, okay, alles klar.
Entschuldigung, Christian, du wolltest auch was sagen. Aber man kann dem UEFA-Supercomputer zumindest– sorry, ja, man kann dem UEFA-Supercomputer zumindest zugutehalten, dass er sehr viel Fußballromantik an den Tag gelegt hat, dass der Kevin de Bruyne gleich am ersten Spieltag zurück zu Manchester City auswärts führt. Ich glaube, da können wir alle davon ausgehen, dass ihm ein sehr, sehr, sehr schöner Empfang bereitet wird.
Das glaube ich allerdings auch. Also, wenn ihr schnell seid, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, dann habt ihr das noch vor 21 Uhr am heutigen Donnerstag gehört. Ein letztes Mal nochmal kurz in die Liga. Jakob, was hast du noch mit dabei? Zwei große Namen lese ich.
Zwei große Namen und eine der positiven Überraschungen bisher in dieser Saison, das ist nämlich Lille, die nach vier Spieltagen mit zehn Punkten auf Platz 2 stehen, nur am ersten Spieltag in einem wilden Spielpunkte gelassen haben gegen Stadt-Brest, über die wir vielleicht auch in den nächsten Wochen mal sprechen müssen. Schauen wir mal, aber wir sind erstmal bei Lille und da ist der erste große Name Olivier Giroud, der natürlich auch im Sommer durchaus für Aufsehen gesorgt hat. Der ist nach 13 Jahren zurück in Frankreich, nachdem er mit Montpellier Meister geworden war und dann seinen Weg zu Chelsea, Arsenal, Milan und zuletzt dann ja nicht so erfolgreich in der MLS war. Und deswegen hatten da viele auch ein paar Fragezeichen, was diesen Transfer angeht, ob er vielleicht eher so als Maskottchen oder so kommt. Zumal wir ja auch im Serie A-Segment eben schon darüber gesprochen haben, dass ja zwei der wichtigsten Offensivspieler zu Juve gegangen sind, mit Segrova und Jonathan David. Dazu ist auch noch André Gomes gegangen, Rémi Caveya. Also und der Torwart Lucas Chevalier, der zu Paris Saint-Germain gegangen ist. Aber gerade halt in der Offensive hat man echt viele Spieler abgegeben und hat dann mit Giroud ja einen renommierten Spieler geholt. Aber es gab halt Fragen hinter seiner Leistungsfähigkeit. Die hat er allerdings bisher durchaus beeindruckend wiederlegen können, hat nach 11 Minuten im ersten Saisonspiel direkt getroffen, hat auch im zweiten Saisonspiel das entscheidende Tor zum 1-0 gegen Monaco gemacht, hat dann kurz danach noch einen Elfer verschossen, aber das hat dann keine Rolle mehr gespielt. Und was vor allem überrascht hat, dass er in beiden Spielen über 90 Minuten gespielt hat. Und man war sich jetzt nicht so sicher, ob er mit 38 noch unbedingt in der Verfassung ist, wirklich viel der Mannschaft zu geben oder ob er eher eine Option von der Bank wird, vielleicht mal 50, 60 Minuten starten kann. Bisher sieht das aber echt gut aus, was da funktioniert. Drum herum hat Lille ein echt spannendes Gerüst mit vielen jungen Offensivspielern. Matthias Fernandes Pardo ist ein Name, den man sich auf jeden Fall merken sollte, der auch schon im Sturmzentrum jetzt gespielt hat, in einem Spiel, in dem Giro da nicht gestartet ist. Hakan Haraldson ist ein ganz interessanter Isländer, der letzte Saison auch gegen Dortmund, meine ich, das Tor geschossen hat in der Champions League, als die beiden aufeinander getroffen sind. Und der zweite große Name ist einer, der eigentlich gar nicht so eine große sportliche Rolle bisher gespielt hat bei Lille, weil er jetzt mit 18 Jahren immer schon mit vielen Verletzungen auch zu kämpfen hatte. Es ist Ethan Mbappé, der kleine Bruder von Kilian. Der hat jetzt am Wochenende endlich sein erstes Ligatour auch erzielen können, hat das späte 2 zu 1 für Lille gemacht. Und ja, natürlich eine sehr schöne Geschichte für ihn, kommt auch aus der PSG-Jugend und ja, hat viel mit Verletzungen schon zu kämpfen gehabt, noch nicht so viele Minuten gesammelt und jetzt sein erstes Tor geschossen. Und man hofft so ein bisschen darauf, dass er vielleicht jetzt auch eine größere Rolle spielen kann in dieser Saison. Ist ein bisschen anderer Spielertyp als sein großer Bruder, ist kein richtiger Stürmer, ist aber durchaus auch mit Zug nach vorne, so im Mittelfeld, kann auch auf dem Flügel spielen, ist auch schnell, würde einen auch überraschen, wenn es nicht so wäre. Aber da bleibt für ihn jetzt vor allem auch erst mal zu gucken, ob er das sehr verletzungsfrei bleibt. Weil ich habe es jetzt gesagt, mit 18 hatte er schon viele, hat auch letzte Saison vier, fünf Verletzungen gehabt und da viele, viele Spiele deswegen verpasst. Aber an sich ist das wirklich sehr, sehr spannend, was Lille damit nicht ganz so großen Mitteln und trotz der ganzen Abgänge, bisher zusammenspielt. Und das kann man sich sehr gut angucken. Sie sind auch das einzige Team, was noch ungeschlagen ist neben PSG.
Allerdings, und das muss wirklich undankbar sein, Bruder von Kilian Mbappé zu sein und ihm auch noch so ähnlich zu sehen. Also es sieht ja wirklich so aus, als hätte sich Kilian eine Perücke aufgesetzt. Ich sehe es hier gerade bei einem Spielerbild. Ja, Lille, werden wir im Blick behalten, spielen ja auch in der Europa League mit. Das heißt, auch da gibt es ja so manches interessante Spiel, das man auch mal jenseits von der Liga mitverfolgen kann. Was haben wir denn in der Premier League noch, Chris, zu besprechen?
Ja, Nick Woltemade. Ich finde es aber ganz interessant zu berichten, wie er so eingeschlagen ist im ersten Spiel. Ihm ist tatsächlich etwas gelungen, was vor ihm nur Jürgen Klinsmann und Ilkay Gündogan gelungen ist, nämlich als Deutscher im ersten Spiel in der Premier League auch zu treffen. Er sollte eigentlich gar nicht spielen, aber wegen Verletzungsproblemen kam er von Anfang an direkt zu seiner Chance. Und er war am Anfang ein bisschen nervös, hat man gemerkt, ist nicht alles gelungen, aber wurde dann immer besser und hat dann auch, ich glaube, nach knapp einer halben Stunde direkt das 1-0 geschossen, spielten auch 1-0 aus. Kopfball nach einer Flanke von rechts hat sich gut gegen sein Gegner durchgesetzt und hat dann eingenickt. Und man hat dann auch gemerkt, dann kam so ein bisschen das Selbstbewusstsein dazu, die wir halt auch aus der Bundesliga kennen, hat sich oft auch fallen lassen, ein bisschen im Spielaufbau teilgenommen und auch vorne als Zielspieler überzeugt, also gut den Ball festgemacht, gut seine Mitspieler in Szene gesetzt und ja, war ein gelungener Einstand für ihn. Und Eddie Howe lubte auch seine Spielintelligenz, sein taktisches Verständnis nach dem Spiel. Und ja, heute Donnerstag darf er auch dann direkt zu Hause für Newcastle gegen Barcelona in der Champions League ran. Also eine gute Woche für ihn, würde ich mal sagen.
Ja, und nach den Länderspielen kann man ihn das vielleicht auch wirklich gönnen. Das ist eine Kreutemade. Siehst du auch wieder, wie Emotionen über geplatzte Transfers, hohe Ablösesum, was auch immer da mit reinspielt. In so einen Blick auf einen Spieler, der auch erst 23 Jahre alt ist und einfach nur Fußball spielen will, mit reinspielt. Da muss man schon ein Herz aus Stein haben, um ihm das nicht zu gönnen, dass er diesen Einstand bei Newcastle haben dürfte. Danke für dieses Update und dann springen wir nochmal in die Serie A. Christian, was müssen wir da noch besprechen?
Ja, machen wir noch zum zum Rausschmeißen noch ein kleines Feel-Good. Cremonese ist einer der Aufsteiger in Italien, haben jetzt wahrscheinlich die wenigsten auf dem Zettel. Cremona, eine Stadt in Norditalien. Cremonese in den letzten 30 Jahren, jetzt erst zum dritten Mal, 33 Jahren glaube ich, zum dritten Mal in der Serie A. Also eigentlich was ganz besonderes, dass die Serie A spielen. Ein historischer Name vielleicht dazu, Gianluca Vialli, der vielleicht noch den Älteren was sagt. Der kommt aus der Cremonese-Jugend. Also da gab es früher schon immer wieder mal ein paar große Namen. Ja, die kehren in die Serie A zurück und spielen am ersten Spieltag in San Siro gegen Milan und gewinnen das Ding einfach mal 2-1. Noch nie Cremonese in San Siro gewonnen, logisch historisch. Legen dann am zweiten Spieltag gleich gegen direkten Konkurrenten, denn für Cremonese geht es logischerweise einzig und allein gegen den Abstieg. Legen gleich ein 3-2-Sieg gegen Sassuolo noch, also dem zweiten Aufsteiger. Stehen also noch zwei Spieltage mit sechs Punkten dra. Und haben jetzt am dritten Spieltag direkt das Duell wieder gegen Hellas, auch ein Abstiegskonkurrent. Auswärts einfach zwar gelitten, aber 0-0 geholt, sprich drei Spiele, sieben Punkte. Keine Sorge, ich mache Cremonese jetzt nicht zu einem Europapokal. Wie sagt man Kandidaten? Aber was man sagen kann, sie haben jetzt schon sechs Punkte Vorsprung auf den ersten Nicht-Abstiegsplatz, das nach geschmeidigen drei Spielen. Also wenn man sich daran erinnert, in der Serie A haben in den letzten Jahren manchmal schon 31, 32 Punkte gereicht, um in der Liga zu bleiben. Dann würde ich sagen, haben die ein knappes Viertel oder ein Fünftel ihrer Punkte schon eingefahren. Große Euphorie logischerweise, allein dieser San Siro Sieg und der letzte Namen. Am letzten Transfertag hat sich Krimonese Jamie Vardy geholt. Ja, Jamie Vardy spielt jetzt für Krimonese. Auch würde ich sagen, eine sehr schöne Geschichte. Ich glaube, Jamie Vardy ist auch bei vielen Fußballfans sehr positiv behaftet, hat jetzt sein Debüt gefeiert, eben gegen Hellas, ist eingewechselt worden. Und Chris, muss ich dir sagen, ich konnte Vardy jetzt die letzten Saison nicht einschätzen, was der noch so geleistet hat, aber hat mich sehr überrascht. Der hat letztes Jahr noch 9 Premier League Puden gemacht, habe ich gesehen. Also, obwohl er logischerweise nicht mehr der Jüngste ist, glaube ich, weiß der weiterhin, wo das Tor steht. Dementsprechend glaube ich, diese Geschichte, Vardy plus Krimmonese, kleiner Verein, schöner Startgeschichte, würde ich sagen, nette Feel-Good-Geschichte.
Ich hoffe, da gibt es genügend Energydrinks, weil Jamie Vardy ist dafür bekannt, sich das eine oder andere Red Bull am Tag zu gönnen. Vielleicht hält das ihn noch hier oben gescheitern.
Ja, ich glaube, die werden es sich finden lassen. Jamie Vardy hat sich ja anscheinend ein bisschen an Norditalien verliebt. Der war ja zuletzt öfter bei Cormo auch zu sehen. Da war er im Stadion auch noch bei der Aufstiegsfeier. Krimmona ist jetzt nicht so weit weg von Cormo, nicht so weit weg von Mailand, nicht so weit weg von Bologna. Also ich glaube, das ist vielleicht auch eine schöne Lebensentscheidung, dass er verstanden hat, dass es da vielleicht sich auch ganz gut geben lässt.
Immer noch mal eine meiner Lieblingsstellen aus der Miru Klose-Biografie von Ronny Reng. Miru Klose, sein ganzes Leben lang asketisch gelebt, Körperfettanteil von minus 0,5. Er wechselt in die Serie A und seine Mitspieler nehmen ihn zur Seite und sagen Miru, du musst mal später essen. Wir essen hier nicht um 19 Uhr. Du kannst nicht immer um 10 Uhr ins Bett gehen. Hier hast du mal diese Nachspeise probiert und auf einmal Körperfettanteil 9 Prozent. Und es geht ihm aber besser denn je. Also das kann passieren.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, das Schöne ist, man kann ihn nur, weil man es sich gut gehen lässt. Bedeutet, es ist ja nicht Miru Klose das beste Beispiel, dass man schon trotzdem noch Leistung bringen kann. Und was für eine Leistung damals auch bei Lazio. Und ja, kann ich echt nur jedem empfehlen, dieses Buch, was du angesprochen hast. Da gibt es so wunderbare Szenen, wenn man über das Essen spricht. Ich erinnere mich noch an eine, die Tropea Zwiebel. Also die sind in Italien halt bei ganz vielen Gerichten, ist die sozusagen fester Bestandteil. Überraschenderweise hat die Klose nicht gekannt, aber er hat dann irgendwann angefangen, selbst zu kochen, die ganzen italienischen Gerichte nachzukochen, war dann immer extrem. Diese Zwiebel musste es sein, weil sonst hätte er dieses Gericht logischerweise nicht gekocht. Also ich würde sagen, ja, das ging auch mit sportlicher Leistung einher. Man kann das schon sehr gut.
Aber wirklich. Wünscht wir Jamie Vardy auch. Jungs, ich habe Hunger gekriegt. Wir machen jetzt Schluss.
Was Ähnliches, ja.
Vielen, vielen Dank euch natürlich in Abwesenheit an Fabian Pakulat. Herzlichen Dank auch an Chris McCarthy, an Jakob Haffke. Tolles Debüt. Und an Christian Bernhard. Danke euch dreien, die ihr jetzt noch hier seid. Danke. Und ich danke natürlich auch euch, lieben Hörerinnen und Hörer. Denn ihr wisst ja, alles, was wir hier im Rasenfunk machen, das ist paywall, Werbe und Sponsoren frei. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich über eure freiwillige Unterstützung. In dieser Folge möchte ich mich bedanken bei voller RWE, bei blubblubhallo und bei bastianfloor auf rasenfunk.de. Da könnt ihr auf den Unterstützen-Button klicken und da erfahrt ihr, wie ihr uns Geld zukommen lassen könnt. Geht auf jedem nur erdenklichen Weg und finanziert alles, was wir hier tun. Empfiehlt uns sehr gerne weiter, tragt es in die Welt hinaus. Die Ligatour geht jetzt auch mit dem europäischen Männerfußball weiter und Zweite Liga gibt es in diesem Format natürlich weiter auch. In diesem Sinne, danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Bleibt oder werdet gesund und bis bald hier im Rasenfunk. Ciao! Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank!